This episode of SmartList is brought to you in part by Skinny Popcorn,
which, yes, is exactly what we were inhaling backstage at the live show.
True story.
There is something very satisfying about a snack that actually delivers and doesn't come
with a paragraph of ingredients.
Skinny Pop keeps it simple.
Real ingredients, classic popcorn.
Nothing weird.
欢迎收听本期 SmartList，本节目部分内容由 Skinny 爆米花赞助。没错，这正是我们在现场后台疯狂往嘴里塞的东西。千真万确。那种真正过瘾、配料表里没有一长串东西的零食，总是让人格外满足。Skinny Pop 保持简单。纯正原料，经典爆米花。没有奇奇怪怪的东西。
Nothing you have to Google.
The original is light and airy, but still hits the spot.
And if you want to mix it up, they got white cheddar, butter, sweet and salty kettle.
It's one of those snacks that works for anything.
Watching something, traveling, pretending, you're only going to have a hand,
Sputty Pop.
Deliciously popped, perfectly salted, popular for a reason.
This episode of SmartList is sponsored by Ashley,
不需要你在谷歌上搜索。原味轻盈蓬松，但依然十分过瘾。如果你想换换口味，他们有白切达干酪、黄油、甜咸风味。这是一种适合任何场合的零食。看节目、旅行、假装你只吃一把，Sputty Pop。美味爆开，盐度完美，受欢迎是有原因的。本期 SmartList 由 Ashley 赞助，
the brand that helped turn our live event stage
into a fully-styled living space.
And it's not just about looks.
Their stuff is built to hold up to the real life
with durable materials and easy to clean fabric.
For the live show, we were on their Mod Max sofa.
It's modular so you can kind of move it around however you want.
you want depending on your space.
这个品牌将我们的现场活动舞台变成了一个设计感十足的起居空间。而且不仅仅是外表好看。他们的产品采用耐用材料和易于清洁的面料，能够经受住真实生活的考验。在现场演出中，我们坐的是他们的 Mod Max 沙发。它是模块化的，所以你可以根据自己的空间，
Honestly, that setup worked perfectly for the show.
I'm not kidding. I would have taken that whole setup home.
It looked great. It felt very comfortable.
Really did feel like we were just hanging out in someone's living room.
Ashley's all about style that's made for real life with white glove delivery right to your room of choice.
Visit your local Ashley store or head to ashley.com to find your style.
Smartlist Live at the Avalon, Hollywood.
Tried to come out last and make some big entrance.
随心所欲地重新摆放。老实说，这个布景对演出来说简直完美。我没开玩笑。我真想把整套布景都搬回家。看起来太棒了。坐着非常舒服。真的感觉就像在某人的客厅里闲逛一样。Ashley 专注于为真实生活而设计的时尚，并提供送货上门并送至你指定房间的优质服务。请访问你当地的 Ashley 门店或登录 ashley.com 寻找你的风格。Smartlist 荷lywood 雅芳剧院现场。我本来想最后一个出场，来个隆重的入场。
No, no, no, no, no.
What happened?
I got, I got caught up back there.
Anyway, hey, I'm here now.
Hey!
One more crack at it.
Get one more crack at it.
Let him have one more crack.
不，不，不，不，不。怎么回事？我被，我被困在后面了。不管怎样，嘿，我现在在这儿了。嘿！再来一次机会。再给他一次机会。让他再来一次。
Guys, we're so excited, we're here, and thank you for coming out tonight.
This is very exciting for us.
I gave Sean a big smack across the face right before we came out, and I'm just waiting for to hit me back.
So it's just pardon me if I'm over here.
It was so loud, I can't believe you heard it.
It's a little bit red over here.
It's become kind of a tradition before...
伙计们，我们太激动了，我们来了，谢谢大家今晚能来。这对我们来说非常激动人心。我刚上台前狠狠打了肖恩一巴掌，我正等着他打回来呢。所以如果我站在这一边，请见谅。声音太大了，真不敢相信你们听见了。我这边的脸有点红。我这边的脸有点红。这已经成了一种传统，在……
There we'll do it.
We'll do it.
No.
This is how we'll do.
Just keep him in a clinch.
It was so fucking hard.
Fix your mic.
The guy got, it's terrible.
行，我们来。我们来。不。我们这样来。就一直搂着他。刚才那一巴掌真他妈重。整理一下你的麦克风。这家伙，太糟糕了。
All right, so we're very thrilled to be here.
Huh?
The rest of the show is going to be less violent.
Best violent.
Okay, that's good.
This is our second time here at the Avalon.
Thank you for having us.
Let's sit.
好了，我们很高兴能来到这里。啊？接下来的演出会没那么暴力。最暴力。好吧，这挺好。这是我们第二次来到雅芳剧院。谢谢你们邀请我们。我们坐吧。
Come on, let's sit.
Thank you guys for come.
I'm going to do a little set.
Okay, yeah, go for it.
This should be good.
Now, thank you guys for coming.
Look at these.
We got our nice, our nice,
来吧，我们坐下。谢谢你们的到来。我要做一小段开场。好吧，行，开始吧。这应该不错。现在，谢谢你们的到来。看看这些。我们有漂亮的，漂亮的……
We want to thank her sponsor.
We got a nice stuff to sit on from Ashley.
Yeah.
We got some nice stuff from me.
I mean, it's real homey.
Right?
It's like a little living room set.
Who wants to?
我们要感谢我们的赞助商。我们有 Ashley 提供的好东西可以坐。对。我们有来自我的好东西。我是说，这真的很温馨。对吧？就像一个小客厅套装。谁想要……
Oh, yeah.
T-shirts.
Got a couple of T-shirts here.
Look alive, everybody.
No fighting.
We're sorry there's no, there's...
I don't know.
Close.
哦，对。T恤。这里有几件T恤。大家打起精神来。不准打架。很抱歉这里没有，没有……我不知道。很接近。
Very close.
I couldn't get it up there.
We got more coming.
We got more where that came from.
That hurt.
Jason leaves tomorrow.
Jason leaves...
I'm going to go work tomorrow.
非常接近。我没能把它扔上去。我们还有更多的。后面还有很多。这一下真疼。杰森明天要走。杰森要……我明天要去工作。
Because this isn't work.
This is fun.
I'm going to go.
I have to leave my family for a good long stretch.
Now you know how my dad feels.
Huh? Yeah.
This is...
It's high-class problems.
因为这不是工作。这是在玩。我要走了。我得离开家人好长一段时间。现在你知道我爸爸是什么感觉了吧。啊？对。这是……这是高级烦恼。
I'm not complaining.
But it's hard because I've been home for like a year.
I know.
Now I'm not.
going to be home for three weeks.
But it's exciting because you're going to direct a film that he's, right?
And it's very, to us, it's very thrilling.
To you, it's work, but to us it's very thrilling that you're going to get behind the
我不是在抱怨。但这很难，因为我已经在家呆了大约一年了。我知道。现在我不能在家呆三个星期了。但这让人兴奋，因为你要导演一部电影，他演的，对吧？对我们来说，这非常激动人心。对你来说这是工作，但对我们来说，你能再次退居
camera again and wow us with this other talent that you have that not a lot of people have.
And it's very exciting.
I think everybody's happy that you're going behind the camera again, you know?
I think you make, because you're a good director.
Yeah.
Right.
That wasn't a compliment.
was it? Did he sneak in an insult?
幕后，用你许多人所没有的另一种才华让我们惊叹，这非常令人兴奋。这真的很让人激动。我想每个人都很高兴你能再次执导电影，你知道吗？我想你会拍出好作品，因为你是个好导演。对吧。刚才那不是句夸奖，对吧？他是不是偷偷损了我一句？
No. No. But you just got
back from working away from home for a long time,
but you had Scotty with you, so
all you missed was Ricky. What a show!
Yes, we were gone for three months,
we just got back last week. But
Amanda will be with you in New York, right?
No, she's going to be here.
没有。没有。但你刚从外面工作很长时间回来，不过你有斯科蒂陪着，所以你只错过了里基。真是场精彩的演出！是的，我们离开了三个星期，我们上周才回来。不过阿曼达会和你在纽约一起，对吧？不，她会在这儿。
Frannie's going to be with me
after a little while, and then
Amanda and Maple are going to come out
for a little bit. You know what, just email me the it
itinerary, we're good.
Yeah.
What did you end up doing with your dog when you were in New York for so long?
We left the dog, nobody knows, actually.
弗兰妮过一会儿会跟我在一起，然后阿曼达和梅普尔会过来呆一会儿。你知道吗，把行程表发电子邮件给我，我们就搞定了。好吧。你在纽约呆了那么久，你的狗最后怎么处理的？我们把狗留下了，其实没人知道。
The dog is still missing.
No, we left put the dog in a, what's it called?
When you board them?
Prison?
No, when you board them?
No, I'm just saying what it felt like for the dog.
No, we, we, yeah, it's cost of fortune, but he was with other dogs and he could play, and he was good.
He seemed happy.
狗现在还是失踪状态。不，我们把狗放在了一个，叫什么来着？寄养的时候？监狱？不，寄养的时候？不，我只是说这对狗来说感觉像什么。不，我们，我们，是的，花了一大笔钱，但它跟其他狗在一起，它可以玩，它很好。它看起来很高兴。
He seemed happy when we talked.
to him on the phone. Yeah.
No, he's good.
Are you guys just meeting for the first time?
What's happening?
This is the weirdest.
I'm so far away.
I know.
我们在电话里跟它说话时，它看起来很高兴。对，它很好。你们俩是刚见面吗？怎么回事？这太奇怪了。我离得好远。我知道。
Well, it's different than the podcast.
We are going to have a guest that's going to come out here in a second.
So that's why we're all separated.
We do have a guess.
Sean and I don't know who the guest is.
I really don't.
That's a true story.
Wait, but wait.
嗯，这和播客不一样。我们待会儿会请一位嘉宾出来。这就是为什么我们都分开坐。我们的确有个嘉宾。肖恩和我不知道嘉宾是谁。我真的不知道。千真万确。等等，但是等等。
We never know.
We truly never know who the guest every once in a while
somebody who on our...
Except for like the presidents of the United States.
The presidents we knew.
Yeah.
But we really don't know, and so it's always a surprise,
and we do never talk about what we're going to talk about.
我们从来不知道。我们真的从来不知道嘉宾是谁，偶尔会有某个人在我们……除了像美国总统。总统我们知道。对。但我们真的不知道，所以这总是一个惊喜，而且我们从来不讨论我们要聊些什么。
The difference with this, though, is that usually you guys, we guys,
I don't do it, but you guys, when I bring on a guest, when we get on the microphone.
I see you guys typing on your computer quickly Googling that person as soon as they come on.
No, no, not because they don't know it, but like to come up with questions and stuff like,
you're not going to have that.
That's fucking bullshit.
No, it is a bullshit.
I don't do that.
不过，这其中的区别在于，通常你们，我们，我不会这么做，但你们，当我请来嘉宾，当我们开始录音时。我看到你们在电脑上飞速打字，一等他们上台就立刻谷歌这个人。不，不，不是因为他们不知道，而是为了想问题之类的，你们可没有这个待遇。这他妈纯属扯淡。不，这确实是扯淡。我才不那样。
I see you typing away.
Sean definitely does that.
I do it, but if I don't know the person, it's like if a sports person comes on.
You just write?
I do not do that.
How dare you accuse me of that?
What are you basing that on?
No.
我看见你在飞速打字了。肖恩绝对干过这事。我确实这么干过，但如果我不认识这个人，比如来了一个体育界的人。你就直接写？我才没有那么做。你怎么能这样指责我？你这是凭什么断定的？没有。
What are you playing with when you're like, I'm messaging people, dude.
I'm busy.
Yes, you're just going to have to wing it.
No, I'm going to have to wing it.
No, I don't know who it is.
And so you're going to like him.
I like him.
He's a friend of mine.
你在敲击什么呢，就像，我在给别人发消息，老兄。我很忙。没错，你只能临场发挥了。不，我只能临场发挥。不，我不知道他是谁。所以你会喜欢他的。我喜欢他。他是我的一个朋友。
Wait, can I, before that, can I tell, I just have a little something I brought with me that I want to show everybody.
Oh boy, he loves to prepare.
We got to watch Shuns Real.
Yes.
So, so today, today, only eight hours ago at 11.05 a.m. this morning, Scotty and I chatted with a friend of ours.
Did you say shatted?
Chatted.
Sorry.
等等，在我说这个之前，我能不能，我刚带了一点小东西来，我想给大家看看。哦天哪，他最喜欢做准备了。我们得看看肖恩的视频。对。所以，今天，就在今天，仅仅八个小时前，也就是今天上午11点05分，斯科蒂和我跟我们的一个朋友聊了天。你刚才说拉了？聊了。抱歉。
You can't hear ourselves up here. I'm so sorry.
Howie brought a friend over and we just chat everywhere.
1105, we both happened to chat.
No, no, we chatted with a friend of ours and a friend of ours and a friend of the podcast.
And it's pretty unbelievable.
And we cut together, Scotty cut together this 20-second video to show you what we did only eight hours ago today.
This is what happened.
Okay.
我们在台听不见自己的声音。非常抱歉。豪伊带了一个朋友过来，我们到处聊天。11点05分，我们俩刚好聊了天。不，不，我们跟我们的一个朋友、播客的一个朋友聊了天。这简直难以置信。我们剪辑了一段，斯科蒂剪辑了一段20秒的视频，来向大家展示我们今天八个小时前做的事情。这就是当时发生的事。好吧。
Are we going to the tape?
Yeah.
We haven't seen this.
Hello to everybody at the Avalon.
What?
Isn't that crazy?
Do you look at her shirt?
That is so cool.
我们要放录像了吗？对。我们还没看过这个。向雅芳剧院的所有人问好。什么？这太疯狂了吧？你看到她的衬衫了吗？太酷了。
Okay, can you see my reflection?
Yes.
That is wild.
Just looking at the shirt.
Look at that.
Okay, ready?
Yep.
Ha, ha, ha.
好了，你能看到我的倒影吗？能。太疯狂了。就看着那件衬衫。看那个。好了，准备好了吗？行。哈哈哈哈。
I'm putting into our kitchen right now, so this seems like our kitchen table.
This is our, this is how we've worn.
up food. We got some garlic and onions and some fresh fruit.
That's got to make the place smell real good.
Isn't that amazing?
Wow.
That is so cool.
That was this morning.
我现在正走进我们的厨房，所以这看起来就像我们的餐桌。这是我们的，这就是我们热食物的方式。我们有一些大蒜、洋葱和一些新鲜水果。那一定让这个地方闻起来很香。这不是很神奇吗？哇。太酷了。那是今天早上的事。
And she's like, do you want to just chat?
I'm like, on the fucking international space station?
Yeah.
So for 45 minutes, we were just chatting.
She showed us around.
She showed us the Russian astronauts and the Japanese section and the, I don't know.
It was crazy.
How cool is that to see your?
然后她说，你想随便聊聊吗？我说，在国际空间站上吗？对。所以我们聊了45分钟。她带我们参观了四周。她给我们看了俄罗斯宇航员、日本舱段，还有，我不知道。太疯狂了。看到你们的……
are government, you know, tax dollars at work.
Wait, do you be smartless?
Did you say 45 minutes, you talk?
45 minutes we hung out with her today.
Isn't that cool?
Was there a phone number?
No, she sends us a link to, like,
not Zoom, but something else.
政府，你知道的，纳税人的钱在发挥作用，这是多么酷的一件事。等等，你刚才说 Smartless？你刚才说聊了45分钟？我们今天跟她闲聊了45分钟。这不是很酷吗？上面有电话号码吗？没有，她给我们发了一个链接，不是 Zoom，是别的什么。
But wait, yeah, Google Meet or whatever.
So wait, I wrote down these things.
She, they are moving five miles a second.
And they rotate.
the Earth every 90 minutes. That's how fast they're going. Isn't that crazy? And I said,
what experience they're working on? She said, something like astronauts get blood clots, so they're
doing some of that. And they're growing crops like Matt Damon and the Martian, and their DNA
therapeutics, protein crystals, future propulsion systems. But what's fascinating is that she said,
但等等，对，Google Meet 之类的。所以等等，我记下了这些事。他们以每秒五英里的速度移动。并且每90分钟绕地球一周。这就是他们的飞行速度。这不是很疯狂吗？我说，他们在做什么实验？她说，类似于宇航员会出现血栓，所以他们在做这方面的研究。他们还在像《火星救援》里的马特·达蒙那样种植农作物，还有他们的 DNA 疗法、蛋白质晶体、未来推进系统。但最迷人的是她说，
when you go up there, something happens to the back of your eyes because there's no gravity
and it flattened the back of her eyes. So she doesn't need glasses on Earth anymore.
Isn't that amazing?
She doesn't he glasses?
And so she has 20-20 vision.
What's that book you're reading?
I just saw you.
It's my phone.
当你去到那里时，因为没有重力，你的眼球后部会发生某种变化，这压扁了她眼球的后部。所以她在地球上再也不需要戴眼镜了。这不是很神奇吗？她不需要戴眼镜了？所以她现在拥有20/20的视力。你在看什么书？我刚刚看到你了。那是我的手机。
Anyway, I just wanted to share that with you
because that happened today.
How are you?
Because I remember when she was on the podcast.
Yeah.
We must have covered this, but remind me,
how are you friends with an astronaut?
Because of the podcast.
不管怎样，我只是想跟你们分享这个，因为这是今天刚发生的。你好吗？因为我记得她上播客节目的时候。对。我们肯定聊过这个，不过提醒我一下，你是怎么跟一个宇航员成为朋友的？通过播客。
What's with the look on your face?
It's so shitty.
But this guy doesn't...
Why are you mad at it?
Why are you mad at him?
He doesn't know anybody.
He never leaves his house.
He barely knows his dog.
你脸上是什么表情？真够操蛋的。但这家伙不……你为什么对它生气？你为什么对他生气？他不认识任何人。他从不出门。他几乎连自己的狗都不认识。
He knows Scotty pretty good.
What happens is he meets people,
and they want to continue to have a relationship
because he's nice.
He doesn't have a shitty look on his face.
And by the way, you just described yourself,
and you were describing me.
Yeah, isn't that wild?
他跟斯科蒂挺熟的。情况是这样的，他结识了其他人，而别人因为他为人友善，都想继续和他保持联系。他可没有一张操蛋的脸。顺便说一句，你刚才那番话就是在形容你自己，而你其实是在形容我。对，这难道不疯狂吗？
Anyway.
Isn't that cool?
I just can't believe you can actually communicate.
So she's currently on the space stage.
Till September.
Wow.
And I'm complaining about going to Jersey for three weeks.
Yeah.
不管怎样。这不是很酷吗？我只是不敢相信你们居然能进行交流。所以她目前还在空间站上。直到九月。哇。而我还在抱怨要去新泽西呆三周。对。
Exactly.
But we can talk to her again.
We can hop on there.
I asked her tons of questions.
She loves it.
They love it.
Jamie, were you thinking about, like,
how fluid would move differently if you were up there,
没错。但我们可以再跟她通话。我们可以连线上去。我问了她一大堆问题。她很喜欢。他们很喜欢。杰米，你有没有想过，如果你在太空中，体液的流动方式会有什么不同，
like in your face and stuff?
You know, you do look puffy when they do those little hits from out of space.
I wouldn't be into it.
No, no.
I just do radio from up there.
But it does.
It lifts.
Radio.
比如在你的脸部之类的？你知道的，当他们在太空中进行那些连线时，你看上去确实有点浮肿。我对这个可不感兴趣。不，不。我只是从上面做广播。但确实如此。它会提升。广播。
Sorry, guys, cameras not working again.
That's what I keep saying.
Radio from space.
No, I don't care about...
This is just a bit.
I don't care about that stuff.
All right, so there's no vanity.
Sean, do you have any more bits?
抱歉，伙计们，摄像头又不好用了。这就是我一直在说的。来自太空的广播。不，我不在乎……这只是个梗。我才不在乎那些东西呢。好吧，所以没有虚荣心。肖恩，你还有别的梗吗？
Any more stuff for us?
Any more pre-tape, Sean?
Yeah.
I always have tons of stuff.
I just said that we never do anything planned,
and then you went to a video package.
Yeah, well, I wanted to make sure,
I wanted to make sure I left space
还有什么东西给我们看吗？还有录好的带子吗，肖恩？对。我总是有成吨的东西。我刚说过我们从来不做任何有计划的安排，然后你就放了一段视频。对，好吧，我只是想确保，我想确保我给她留了空间，但我不知道该怎么计划。哦天哪，我找不到我为该死的嘉宾写的开场白了。太真实了。迈克尔，请把那些卡片拿给我。该死。那还有什么新鲜事？太离谱了。你知道，我最近刚戒烟。
for her, but I didn't know how to plan it.
Oh my God, I can't find my intro that I wrote for the freaking guest.
This is so real.
Michael, bring me those cards down, please.
God damn it.
So what else is going on?
Unreal.
You know, I just quit smoking recently.
不，你没有。等等，什么？你戒了？烟熏梅普尔·贝特曼，是的，梅普尔·贝特曼。梅普尔·贝特曼。
No, you didn't.
Wait, what?
You did?
Smoky
Maple Bateman
Yeah, Maple Bateman.
Maple
Bateman.
好吧，今晚要彻底搞砸了。好吧。现在开始即兴发挥。开场白，介绍嘉宾。可以简短点。这家伙，我是一个演员。
All right, this is going to be a disaster
tonight.
All right.
Freestyling now.
Intro, the guest.
It can be short.
This guy
I'm an actor.
这本该是写给我的，然后我看看。我能看见你的汗。我知道。我现在满头大汗。好吧。好吧，所以这家伙，他很极端。我认为他是我们拥有的最伟大的喜剧演员之一。
It's supposed to be written for me
and then I see.
I can see your sweat.
I know.
I'm in deep sweat right now.
Okay.
Okay, so this is a fella who he is extreme.
I think he's one of the greatest comedic actors we have.
句号。好吗？这是 A，这是一个好的开始，对吧？看我即兴发挥。但他不仅能让你笑。他有时还能让你哭。看看还有什么？所有的手机都举起来了。
Full stop.
Okay?
That's A, that's a good start, right?
See me vamping.
But he doesn't just make you laugh.
He makes you cry sometimes.
Look at what else?
All the phones are up.
怎么回事？我感觉自己就像爱莉安娜·格兰德。他曾凭优秀的电影两次获得奥斯卡提名，对吧？不仅仅是喜剧。这家伙是个大人物。他还自己写剧本并导演电影。拍过好几部了。
What's going on?
I feel like Ariana Grande.
He's been nominated.
twice for an Oscar for fancy movies, right?
Not just the comedy stuff.
This guy's a big shot.
He's also writes and directs movies.
Done a few of those.
是谁，瑞安·雷诺兹？不，他还没写过或导演过电影。我发现，虽然他才华横溢，但他的内心更加善良，因为我们在过去几年里成为了朋友。你认识他是因为《忘家莎拉·马歇尔》。你认识他是因为《一夜大肚》、《四十岁的老处男》。
What is it, Ryan Reynolds?
No, he hasn't written or directed a film yet.
And I have found that while he's incredibly talented,
his heart's even bigger because we've become friends
over the past few years.
You know him from.
Forgetting Sarah Marshall.
You know him from Knocked Up, 40-year-old Virgin.
你认识他是因为《超级坏》、《点球成金》、《华尔街之狼》。女士们先生们，独一无二的乔纳·希尔。我当然在流汗了。我在想，老兄，他到底会说些什么？你好吗？我已经很紧张了。我在想，哦，他已经他妈的……是的，你当时在想什么……
You know him from Super Bad Moneyball Wolf of Wall Street.
Ladies and gentlemen, the one and only Jonah Hill.
Of course, I'm sweating.
I'm like, what is you going to say, dude?
How are you?
I was already nervous.
I'm like, oh, he already fucking...
Yeah, what were you thinking...
乔纳，贝特曼用开场白搞砸的时候，你在后台是怎么想的？这简直就是全盘皆输。我只是重新回到这种人群之类的场合。我老婆在这儿。我在想……我在想，好吧，杰森会罩着我的。
Jonan, what were you thinking backstage
when Bateman blew it with the intro?
That it's just a total wipeout.
I'm just coming back out here, like,
in crowds and stuff.
My wife's here.
I'm like...
And I'm like, okay, Jason's going to hook me up.
乔纳恩，贝特曼在开场白搞砸的时候，你在后台是怎么想的？这就全盘皆输了。我只是重新回到这里，比如在人群之类的地方。我妻子也在这里。我就想……然后我就想，好吧，杰森会帮我的忙的。
And he's like, oh, I don't have an intro.
So I'm sitting back there going, like,
he's going, like, he's a guy.
that I'm friends with that I text with
and like I was like oh fuck
he probably wrote something nice and now it's going to get
like dumb down to
you know how to improvise
然后他说，哦，我没有准备开场白。所以我坐在后台心想，他就好像，他是我一个朋友，我会给他发短信，然后我就想，操，他可能写了些好东西，现在要被降格成你知道的即兴发挥了。
I'm all right at the improvising but you're
you're the Mac dad you and Vince Vaughn
no one better brilliant
ever
brilliant
all right so
right so you're not in front of crowds all the time
you're not up in L.A. You're down in San Diego
我即兴发挥还行，但你才是大腕，你和文斯·沃恩，没人比你们更优秀，简直才华横溢，太棒了。好，对吧，所以你不是一直在观众面前，你不在洛杉矶，你在圣迭戈。
for the most part now
oh you live in San Diego? Oh yeah so
Okay, so real quick, before we go in any further, my wife is here,
my best friend and business partner, Matt Dines, is here.
Shout out to my beautiful wife, Liv.
Where is she?
Oh, what's up, baby?
And then, so I live in a very small town in San Diego, and it's amazing,
大部分时间现在是这样，哦，你住在圣迭戈？哦，对，所以，好吧，等一下，在我们继续之前，我妻子在这，我最好的朋友兼商业合伙人马特·代恩斯在这。向我美丽的妻子利夫致敬。她在哪？哦，怎么了，宝贝？然后，我住在圣迭戈的一个小镇上，那儿太棒了，
and my neighbors are incredible people.
And when we had our first kid, we moved out there three years ago.
And my neighbors are so cool.
I wanted to leave L.A. and raise a family outside of Los Angeles.
and away from entertainment and I could maybe come back and then, you know, go back and forth.
And my neighbors are so cool.
They never, like, treat me weird or ask me about my job or anything.
And my neighbor is one of my great friends, Dr. Sean.
我的邻居都是了不起的人。当我们有第一个孩子时，我们三年前搬到了那里。我的邻居太酷了。我想离开洛杉矶，在洛杉矶之外养育家庭，远离娱乐业，也许我以后可以再回来，然后，你知道的，两边跑。我的邻居太酷了。他们从来不会，你知道的，对我大惊小怪，或者问我关于工作的事。我的邻居是我最好的朋友之一，肖恩医生。
You're welcome.
He never asked.
He's here tonight.
Whoa.
But hold on.
He never bothered me.
It was like, oh, what's this person?
And then, like, after like, a year we were in the sauna, just chilling, like, two dads.
不用客气。他从来不问。他今晚也来了。哇。但是等等。他从不烦我。就像，哦，这个人是谁？然后，大概过了一年，我们在桑拿房里，就很放松，像两个老爸一样，
and he goes, can I ask you one question?
And I was like, yeah, sure, man.
And he's like, it's Jason Bateman a cool guy?
And that was his one question about show business.
And I was like, yeah, he's an amazing guy.
And he goes, he's like, it's fucking cool.
I'm a big fan of his.
So shout out to Dr. Sean and Dr. Bob and Heidi and Laura.
然后他问，我能问你个问题吗？我就说，行啊，老兄。然后他说，杰森·贝特曼是个酷哥吗？这就是他关于演艺圈的唯一问题。然后我说，对，他是个了不起的人。接着他说，太酷了。我是他的超级粉丝。所以向肖恩医生、鲍勃医生、海蒂和劳拉致敬。
I love you guys.
Welcome.
You know what?
It sounds like J.B.
you might be able to get in that sauna with these guys.
Yeah, listen, I love a good sauna.
What do you think? Dr. John, do you think?
J.B. is good in the sauna?
我爱你们。欢迎。你知道吗？听起来，杰·贝，你也许能和这些家伙一起蒸桑拿。对，听着，我喜欢蒸桑拿。你觉得呢？约翰医生，你觉得呢？杰·贝桑拿技术好吗？
I get super nice in the schvitz.
Jonah.
Yeah, nice to see you all.
Thanks for having you.
Jonah, thank you for doing this.
This is a very easy no.
And you said yes.
You know, you could just say,
我在蒸汽房里人超好。乔纳。很高兴见到大家。谢谢你们邀请我。乔纳，谢谢你来做客。这完全是个不用想就会拒绝的邀请。而你却答应了。你知道的，你本可以说，
oh, I'm down in San Diego now.
We drove in today.
It was awesome.
Now, will you stay overnight or will you drive back?
Yeah, we're staying at a hotel.
We brought both our kids.
Oh, that's nice.
We have a new little baby who's like,
哦，我现在在圣迭戈呢。我们今天是开车来的。太棒了。那你今晚会留宿还是开车回去？对，我们住酒店。我们把两个孩子都带来了。哦，那太好了。我们有个新生的小宝宝，就像是，
it was just a new brand-new baby,
and then we have almost three-year-old.
Both boys.
That's so nice.
So now, what do you miss about L.A.?
When you come up, what do you like to do?
Oh, you know nothing.
You know, Nussie Walk.
那是个刚出生的新生儿，然后我们还有一个快三岁的。都是男孩。太好了。那么，现在，你怀念洛杉矶的什么？当你上来的时候，你喜欢做什么？哦，你知道的，纳西步道。
I grew up here.
L.A. was such a cool place to grow up in the 90s
because you could like, you know, you could go skateboard downtown
or you could sneak into a movie premiere,
or you could go sneak into a comedy club and see, like, Chris Rock or something.
You had access to, like, show business stuff,
but you had access to, like, punk and skating and graffiti
and all the, like, naughty stuff.
我在这里长大的。90年代在L.A.成长是个太酷的地方，因为你可以，你知道的，你可以去市中心玩滑板，或者你可以溜进电影首映礼，或者你可以溜进喜剧俱乐部去看克里斯·罗克之类的人。你能接触到演艺圈的东西，但你也能接触到朋克、滑板、涂鸦和所有那些淘气的东西。
And there was no internet.
It was just so awesome.
Right.
And it was...
You were skating, right?
Because your first film, mid-90s, which is awesome.
That, like, you certainly were at least familiar with the skating culture.
Do you know your way around a skate park?
而且当时没有互联网。就是这么棒。对。而且你是...你在玩滑板，对吧？因为你的第一部电影，90年代中期，太棒了。那个，就像，你肯定至少对滑板文化很熟悉。你对滑板公园很熟悉吗？
I mean, yeah, I steal skateboard every day.
Come on.
You do, really?
Okay, because my daughter, Maple, I took her to the skate park this morning,
pedlo over there in the valley.
She's working on Pop Shavitz, Ollie's.
She just dropped in last weekend.
Amazing.
我是说，对，我每天都偷滑板。得了吧。真的吗？好吧，因为我女儿梅普，我今天早上带她去了滑板公园，就是山谷里的那个佩德洛。她正在练习踢板转体、尖翻。她上周末刚学会冲滑落。太厉害了。
You're already better than I ever was.
When I say a skateboard every day, now with my son, we surf skate,
which is like way easier.
It's like, I don't do tricks or anything anymore.
I'm too old.
I'm 42.
So surf skate means you're on a long board
and you just kind of cruise you.
你已经比我以前任何时候都厉害了。当我每天说一个滑板时，现在和我儿子一起，我们玩冲浪滑板，这容易多了。就像，我不再做什么技巧了。我太老了。我42岁了。所以冲浪滑板意味着你踩着长板，然后就是那种滑行。
Let's not go crazy.
I'm not on a long board, Jason.
I'm on a short, shorter board, but yeah.
You were part of that skate culture just a little bit.
I loved it.
Yeah, it was amazing.
Like anything skating, hip-hop, and comedy
when I was a kid, I was like anything about any of it,
别开玩笑了。我没有踩长板，杰森。我踩的是短一点的板，但是是的。你曾经对那种滑板文化略知一二。我很喜欢。是的，太棒了。就像我小时候任何滑板、嘻哈和喜剧，我都喜欢关于它们的一切，
all I could.
Did you cross paths with Spike Jones at all back in the day?
Well, I did a ton of.
and Spike is my biggest mentor and one of my best friends.
Incredible director.
What a nice guy, too.
He's, like, one of the most amazing people.
And before I directed mid-90,
我能接触到的都接触了。你当年和斯派克·琼斯有过交集吗？嗯，我合作过很多次。而且斯派克是我最大的导师和最好的朋友之一。了不起的导演。人也太好了。他就像是最了不起的人之一。在我导演《90年代中期》之前，
I wrote mid-90s at his apartment.
Oh, really?
And New York, we were both living in New York,
and I basically spent, like, five years, you know,
after kind of, what was it, like, I've been gone for a while,
so I'm kind of coming back, and I'm, like, excited.
Because I got all, like, serious for a while,
and I wasn't that happy.
我在他的公寓里写了《90年代中期》。哦，真的吗？在纽约，我们俩都住在纽约，我基本上花了大概五年时间，你知道的，在经历了，是什么来着，我离开了一段时间，所以现在算是在回归，而且我很，很兴奋。因为我有一段时间变得很严肃，而且我没那么快乐。
I wasn't that happy.
And then I met, I had my family, and I got happy,
and now all I want to do is be funny again, you know?
So, like, it's a-
You were always funny.
It's a freaking bust.
It's just like, that's why I said yes,
because I'm like, I want to go fucking be funny in front of a crowd,
我没那么快乐。然后我遇到了，我有了家庭，我变得快乐了，现在我只想再次变得有趣，你知道吗？所以，就像，一个——你一直都很有趣。这简直太扯了。这就像，这就是我为什么答应，因为我想，我想去在观众面前变得有趣，
and that'd be awesome, you know?
But the humor, do you find that the humor's coming from
a more substantial place now?
That it's, I mean, you're still, you couldn't shake funny if you try,
but now you've got a whole deeper well of reflection
and knowing yourself more,
and you've peeled the onion,
and now you've got a bunch of other stuff
那会太棒了，你知道吗？但是幽默，你觉得现在的幽默感是不是来自一个更厚重的根基？就是，我是说，你还是，你想甩掉有趣也甩不掉，但现在你有了更深的沉淀和自我认知，你剥开了洋葱，现在你有了更多别的东西，
to draw upon to feed your humor, yes?
Yeah, I think, I mean, speak for me, that's fine.
That's my special.
Hey, guys, I don't need to be here.
There's no intro, and I just drive back to San Diego
and go fuck myself.
I put the question and the answer in it,
and then I say, yeah, it's deep and cool.
可以用来为你的幽默提供养分，对吗？对，我想，我是说，就代表我说话吧，行。那是我的专场。嘿，伙计们，我不需要呆在这。没有开场白，我就直接开车回圣迭戈然后滚蛋。我把问题和答案都写在里面了，然后我说，对，这很深奥很酷。
He could have zoomed in.
Yeah.
Totally.
No, that is a good, that's a good...
Thank you.
Next question.
No, but it's more like,
like, if you're bummed,
他本来可以拉近镜头的。对。完全同意。不，那是个好，那是个好……谢谢。下一个问题。不，但更像是，如果你心情沮丧，
you don't feel like being that funny, right?
And if you're happy,
the first thing I thought about
when I got, like, had my kids
and was so stoked, it was like,
uh,
I connected to back when I was just like 12
and I was just being funny for fun.
你就不想那么搞笑，对吧？如果你很开心，当我有了孩子并且超级兴奋时，我脑子里想的第一件事就是，呃，我回想起我12岁的时候，我只是为了好玩而搞笑。
Right.
And I was like,
that's the thing I fell in love with.
my whole life, like I dedicated my whole life to learning everything about The Simpsons and comedy,
history.
Who did you, when you were growing up in the 90s, who were your influences?
Who were you like, God, that guy is so funny?
Or that show is so funny?
对。然后我想，这就是我爱上的东西。我的一生，就像我把我的一生都奉献给了解关于《辛普森一家》和喜剧历史的一切。你在90年代成长的时候，谁对你影响最大？你觉得，天哪，那家伙太搞笑了？或者那个节目太搞笑了？
Everybody.
Everything.
Like, anything good, bad, or in between?
But like you're so, like Jason said, you're such a genius at improvisation.
The first time I saw you was on a show called Campus Ladies.
Yes.
And one of my best friends, Carrie Aisley is he.
She's right there.
每个人。每件事。就像，任何好的、坏的、或者介于两者之间的？但就像杰森说的，你在即兴表演上是个天才。我第一次看你的演出是在一个叫《校园辣妹》的节目里。是的。我最好的朋友之一，凯莉·艾斯利，她就在那。
Carrie!
Yeah.
And you were on the show with her.
Oh my God, hey, Carrie.
And you met Dr. Sean?
Dude, Carrie, Carrie gave me...
Sean couldn't get them seats.
Carrie gave me a huge break.
凯莉！对。你和她一起出演了那个节目。天哪，嘿，凯莉。你遇到肖恩医生了吗？老兄，凯莉，凯莉给了我——肖恩弄不到那些座位。凯莉给了我一个巨大的机会。
Thank you, Carrie.
He gave me a huge fucking break
when I was like 18.
Yeah.
But I watched you on that show,
and I'm like, oh my, of course you skyrocketed.
You were a brilliant
performer, actor, improviser, all of it.
谢谢你，凯莉。当我大约18岁的时候，他给了我一个巨大的他妈的机会。对。但我看你在那个节目里的表演，我就想，哦，天哪，你当然一飞冲天了。你是个才华横溢的表演者、演员、即兴喜剧演员，什么都是。
And I was just like, who is this person?
So you must have...
I mean, mostly the same.
I think The Simpsons is like the number one thing in the entire world.
Like, if anything's left in impact on my life, it'd be The Simpsons over there.
It's some of the greatest comedy writing of all time.
It's pretty, it's like such a heavy weight.
But that was, obviously, there's no acting in that, except for the voices, obviously.
当时我就想，这个人是谁？所以你一定——我是说，基本上差不多。我觉得《辛普森一家》是全世界第一的事物。如果有什么对我的人生留下影响的话，那就是那边的《辛普森一家》。那是史上最伟大的喜剧编剧之一。这挺，这分量太重了。但那是，显然，这里面没有任何表演，除了配音，显然。
So were you following, like, the writing of that?
Was writing the first poll for you?
Yeah.
Not performing.
So if you, like, shook me in the middle of the night and, like, what do you do?
I'd be like, I'm a comedy writer.
That's what I do.
Like, I write jokes every day.
所以你当时在关注，比如，它的剧本创作吗？写作对你来说是最初的吸引力吗？是的。而不是表演。所以如果你，比如半夜把我摇醒，问我，你做什么的？我会说，我是个喜剧编剧。这就是我的工作。就像我每天都写笑话。
Like, I go and write scripts.
and write scripts.
Like, you don't know this
because you just see the front side of it.
But most of my job is writing comedy movies.
That's, like, mostly what I do.
And when I was young,
I would VHS record The Simpsons
就像，我去写剧本，然后写剧本。就像，你不知道这个，因为你只看到了光鲜的一面。但我大部分的工作是写喜剧电影。那就是，我主要做的事。当我年轻的时候，我会用录像带录下《辛普森一家》，
and then pause it on the writers
and write them all letters.
Wow.
And to this day,
one of my biggest mentors and friends
is David Merkin,
who's like an iconic Simpsons writer.
And every time, like,
然后在编剧那里暂停，给他们每个人写信。哇。直到今天，我最大的导师和朋友之一仍然是大卫·默金，他是《辛普森一家》的标志性编剧。每次，比如，
you've been to a screening
of early cuts in my movies for notes.
like David Merkin comes to every single screening,
every table read,
and he was like my childhood hero.
So I wrote them all letters
when I was like seven, eight years old.
And that was my dream.
你去看过我的电影早期剪辑版并提意见吗？就像大卫·默金会去看每一次放映，每一次剧本围读，他就像是我儿时的英雄。所以我七、八岁的时候就给他们所有人写信了。那就是我的梦想。
Like, like, if I had written for The Simpsons,
that's like, would have been more than enough for...
Did you write a speck Simpson script?
Yeah, I've written a ton of Speck.
Oh, you did?
Did they ever buy one or pick, no.
No, I never like sent them to them like...
Oh, yeah.
就像，如果我能为《辛普森一家》写过剧本，那就已经远远足够……你写过《辛普森一家》的样稿剧本吗？对，我写过一大堆样稿。哦，真的吗？他们买过或者选过吗，没有。没有，我从来没有像那样把它们寄给他们……哦，是的。
As like an eight-year-old.
Yeah, they can't receive...
Oh, okay.
Well, then when did the performance part of it start to take hold?
Like, when did you think that you could be in front of the camera?
Well, I got to think all three of you were like hams, comedic hands, right?
What happened?
作为一个八岁小孩。对，他们不能接收……哦，好吧。哦，好吧。那表演的部分是什么时候开始萌芽的？比如，你是什么时候觉得自己可以走到镜头前面的？好吧，我得认为你们三个都是戏精，喜剧戏精，对吧？怎么回事？
Like, did you just drift off?
He's narcoleptic.
He said, he said we're all hams.
Yeah, we're all hands.
Must have been hams when you were little kids.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Like, if there was, like, a party at my parents' house, I'd do, like, a...
Yeah, yeah.
就像，你们只是随性发挥吗？他有发作性嗜睡症。他说，他说我们都是戏精。对，我们都是戏精。你小时候肯定也是戏精。对，对，对。就像，如果我父母家有派对，我就会做一个，比如……对，对。
Yeah, for sure. Comedy show.
Absolutely.
I feel like everyone here can relate to that.
So it was just always like people were like, oh, you're funny.
And then when I got to middle school, people's parents were like,
you should pull them out of school to my parents and like make them a comedian.
Oh, wow.
对，当然。喜剧秀。绝对的。我觉得这里的每个人都能感同身受。绝对的。所以一直以来就是人们会说，哦，你真搞笑。然后当我上初中时，别人的父母对我的父母说，你应该让他退学，让他去当个喜剧演员。哦，真的吗？
Yeah, people would like say that to.
You were going to schools where there were some people that were in the business,
like the center and cross-rose.
People think I'm a Nepo baby, by the way.
My wife and I were just laughing about this, that I'm a nepo baby.
My dad's a fucking accountant.
If you think, ask these guys, he directs a lot of shit.
Do you ever hire your business manager's son for a fucking black rabbit or whatever?
对，人们会那样对——顺便说一下，你们去的学校里有些人是圈内人，比如中心学校和十字路口学校。人们以为我是个皇亲国戚。我和我妻子刚才还在笑这个，说我是个皇亲国戚。我爸他妈的是个会计。如果你觉得，问问这几位，他导演了很多破事。你有没有雇过你商业经理工的儿子来演什么黑色兔子之类的？
Yeah, huh?
Yeah. No.
You hire Jeffrey Goldstein to play like the heavy and, um, but like,
but Jonah, how old were you when we met?
We met when you were, you were like a, you were young.
Will, should we take a snack break?
Yeah.
Yeah, you were like hanging out at my school, like, um, no, no, no, no.
对吧？嗯？对。没有。你雇杰弗瑞·戈德斯坦去演那种恶霸，呃，但是，但是乔纳，我们见面时你多大？我们见面时你，你还很年轻。威尔，我们要不要吃个零食休息一下？对。对，你当时在我的学校晃悠，就像，呃，不不不不不。
We were like a trench coat on.
Yeah.
No, that was a different.
Newly sober.
You had something different.
Okay, all right, right, right.
No, it was that like, I'm leading by example.
You had this, like, van.
我们穿着风衣。对。不，那是另一回事。刚戒酒。你当时有点不一样。好吧，好吧，对，对，对。不，那是，我以身作则。你当时开着这样一辆面包车。
It was at the Wistler's.
No, so I went to the school called Crossroads,
which is a, like, full leg up
because if you grow up here and go to this school,
everybody's parents are in entertainment.
So, to be fair, it wasn't an abstract job.
That was, like, my big leg up
where I was, like, everybody's parents here
在惠斯勒。不，所以我上过一所叫十字路口的学校，这绝对是个捷径，因为如果你在这里长大并上这所学校，每个人的父母都在娱乐业。所以，公平地说，这不是个抽象的工作。那就像是我的巨大捷径，让我觉得，这里每个人的父母
works in entertainment.
So if you want to, like, write for the Simpsons,
that's not the craziest idea
in the entire world, right?
So that was a huge leg up for me
to just not be like show business as abstract
and far away, right?
Right.
都在娱乐业工作。所以如果你想，比如为《辛普森一家》写剧本，那并不是全世界最疯狂的想法，对吧？所以对我来说，这真是一个巨大的捷径，让我不会觉得演艺圈是那么抽象和遥远，对吧？对。
We were literally, it was Henry Winkler
we were doing the first season of Rest Development
and I went over there for breakfast one Saturday
and you and Max were poutousy.
So Max was like my best friend in high school
was Henry's son and he's an amazing guy
and a great director.
Great director. He just...
我们当时真的是，我们在拍《发展受阻》第一季的时候，是亨利·温克勒，我有一个星期六去他那吃早餐，你和马克斯在……所以马克斯是我高中最好的朋友，是亨利的儿子，他是个了不起的人，也是个伟大的导演。伟大的导演。他只是……
He directs a lot of the Ryan Murphy stuff.
A ton of amazing stuff.
The Charlie Hunnam show he just did
was incredible.
Freak,
monsters.
He's great.
他导演了很多瑞恩·墨菲的作品。大量了不起的作品。他刚做的那部查理·汉纳姆的剧真是太棒了。怪胎，怪物。他太棒了。他太棒了。
And he's an amazing dude, yeah.
And so I met Will, and I remember meeting Will.
You were a kid.
I was so hyped because I was interning for his brother
and Arrested Development and just come out.
And Jake Hoffman, it was another buddy of yours.
He interned on Arrested Development, didn't he?
Yeah.
而且他是个了不起的家伙，对吧。所以我遇到了威尔，我记得见到威尔的时候。你还是个孩子。我当时超级兴奋，因为我在为他兄弟在《发展受阻》里实习，这部剧刚刚播出。杰克·霍夫曼，那是你的另一个朋友。他在《发展受阻》实习过，对吧？对。
Dustin Hoffman's on.
Is that a TV show?
Oh.
Yeah.
Wrested Development.
It's very funny.
Jonah.
Sean's never seen.
达斯汀·霍夫曼的儿子。那是部电视剧吗？哦。对。《发展受阻》。非常搞笑。乔纳。肖恩从没看过。
It's never seen it.
Is that real? Not a bit.
It's real. I saw the first episode.
You guys have the best job in show business.
I'm so jealous of you guys because...
You're on it. This is you're joining us.
We're looking to replace one of us.
But like, you guys have like, it's like being in a writer's room, like you're just
他从来没看过。那是真的吗？不是段子。是真的。我看了第一集。你们拥有演艺圈最棒的工作。我太嫉妒你们了，因为……你就在里面。这是，你加入我们了。我们正打算换掉我们中的一个。但是像你们，你们就像是在编剧室里，就像你们只是
bullshitting with your friends, but you don't have to make the thing at the end.
You just get paid like $100 billion to just show up to the writer's room and never have
to like make the good jokes in or edit out the bad ones.
You're just like, man, let's just sit on the couch and order food.
And I'm like, shit.
So wait.
So you want to be a writer.
You start doing it at eight.
和朋友瞎扯，但最后不用真的把东西做出来。你们只是拿一千亿美元坐在编剧室里，永远不用把好笑的段子留下来或者把烂笑子删掉。你们就像是，老兄，我们就在沙发上坐着点外卖吧。然后我想，操。所以等等。所以你想当编剧。你八岁就开始干了。
You're in a school, schools where the pathway to entertainment industry is not unreasonable.
But at what age do you get the first sort of on-camera idea and then it actually happens?
Are you still, you're still in high school?
I was 18.
So like fresh out of high school, I started working.
And so what's that first job? Do you get an agent?
No, no, no. So it wasn't like that. I went to
New School. I went to Boulder for one semester and got kicked out. My mom calls it her $40,000 sweatshirt.
你在一个学校里，那里的学校通往娱乐业的途径并不是不合理的。但你是在什么年龄第一次有了上镜的想法，然后它真的发生了？你还在，你还在上高中吗？我18岁。所以就像刚高中毕业，我就开始工作了。那么第一份工作是什么？你找经纪人了？不，不，不。所以不是那样的。我去了新学院。我去博尔德呆了一个学期就被开除了。我妈把它叫做她四万美元的卫衣。
And she's really funny. My parents are really funny people and awesome people.
But they, they said I went to new school and in New York City and I started just performing in like in theater school, but then performing at bar.
and doing like kind of stand-up.
Yeah, like stand-up and then like short plays.
And like they would let me perform at this bar called Black and White,
which was an awesome bar.
Did you do Black and White, Willie?
No.
她真的很有趣。我父母是非常有趣的人，也是很棒的人。但他们，他们说我去了纽约市的新学院，然后我开始在，比如在戏剧学校演出，然后在酒吧演出。做那种单口喜剧。对，就像单口喜剧然后还有小短剧。他们会让我在这家叫“黑与白”的酒吧演出，那是个很棒的酒吧。威尔，你在“黑与白”演过吗？没有。
It was so fun.
It was like the most fun time.
And then I started getting like a crowd of people.
And I was already like, it's on, dude.
I was like, it's so going to be on.
You're comfortable in front of an audience.
So going to a camera then is not that much of a leap.
No.
太好玩了。那是最有趣的时光。然后我开始聚集了一群观众。我已经觉得，要起飞了，老兄。我就觉得，这绝对要起飞了。你在观众面前很自在。那么走到镜头前其实也就没那么大跨度了。没有。
And then I got my first job in a movie called I Heart Huckabee's,
which was like my first.
And Jake's dad, Dustin was like, you should be a comedic actor.
So how did that come to be?
How did you get in front of Dustin?
It wasn't like a performance thing or anything.
We were just, I was just friends with his son and he would see me do stuff and was like,
and I make prank call CDs.
然后我得到了我的第一份电影工作，是一部叫《我爱哈克比》的电影，那是我的第一部。杰克的爸爸，达斯汀就说，你应该当个喜剧演员。所以那是怎么发生的？你是怎么站到达斯汀面前的？那不是什么表演之类的事情。我们只是，我只是他儿子的朋友，他看我做一些事情，就觉得，我还制作恶作剧电话光盘。
I make prank call CDs.
I was like a ham.
I was just like trying to be funny all the time.
But you were just making Dustin laugh around the house and he says,
you should read.
Maybe like if Mabel had a friend over it and you are like, you know,
Rob Reiner, rest in peace to the legend.
I fucking love that dude so much.
我制作恶作剧电话CD。我当时就像个活宝。我总是想尽办法搞笑。但你只是在家里逗得达斯汀哈哈大笑，他说，你应该去试镜。也许就像梅贝尔有朋友来家里玩，而你会说，你知道，罗伯·莱纳，传奇人物，愿他安息。我他妈超级喜欢那个家伙。
But, you know, Rob would bring Albert Brooks around,
and Rob would tell me that, like, his dad was like,
Albert is the funniest fucking guy,
but Albert was just Rob's friend.
Right, right, right.
You know, and Albert's Albert Brooks, right?
So, like, Dustin was like,
I'm doing this movie.
但是，你知道，罗伯会带阿尔伯特·布鲁克斯一起来，罗伯会告诉我，比如说，他爸爸觉得，阿尔伯特是他妈的最搞笑的家伙，但阿尔伯特只是罗伯的朋友。对，对，对。你知道的，而且阿尔伯特可是阿尔伯特·布鲁克斯，对吧？所以，达斯汀就说，我在筹备这部电影。
I got you an audition.
And so he got me an audition.
And so you read for the casting director.
She passed it on to David.
David said, yeah, great.
And then you get on that set.
And what's that like being on a set?
You're just looking around.
我给你争取到了一次试镜。于是他帮我弄到了试镜机会。然后你去给选角导演试镜。她把这事转给了大卫。大卫说，行，太棒了。然后你就进组了。在剧组里是什么感觉？你就是四处张望。
Well, David O was fucking nuts at that time, dude.
He was buck wild.
And I'm like, homies with him.
He's awesome.
Super nice guy.
But at that moment in life, and I've had my own, trust me,
he was buck wild, dude.
There's like, you know, he was like screaming at Lily Tomlin and stuff.
好吧，大卫·O当时他妈的简直疯了，老兄。他当时狂野得不得了。我和他是哥们儿。他棒极了。超级好的人。但在他人生的那个阶段，相信我，我自己也经历过，他当时真的是狂野不羁，老兄。那场面，你知道，他甚至对莉莉·汤姆林他们大喊大叫。
It's online.
It's online and shit.
And he'll talk about it.
Like, you know, he's really cool.
He's one of the best directors ever.
I mean, flirting with disaster and three kings.
I mean, he's so goaded.
It's insane.
网上都有。网上到处都是这种事。而且他自己也会谈论这个。就像，你知道的，他真的很酷。他是史上最优秀的导演之一。我是说，《瞒天过海》和《三个国王》。我的意思是，他太受推崇了。这太疯狂了。
And I got on the set, I was like, everyone's screaming at each other.
The first time I walked on set, him and K.K. Barrett, the production designer,
were joking around wrestling, and then it turned into a real fight.
And it was, like, joking that, like, turned into a fight.
And these guys were, like, fighting.
And they were setting up my first scene to act in music.
Welcome to Hollywood.
And I was like, Hollywood is so tight.
当我进组时，我心想，怎么每个人都在互相大喊大叫。我第一次走进片场时，他和美术指导KK·巴雷特正在开玩笑摔跤，然后就演变成了一场真正的打架。这就好比是开玩笑结果假戏真做了。然后这两个家伙就在那儿打起来了。当时他们正在为我在音乐里的第一场戏做准备。欢迎来到好莱坞。当时我觉得，好莱坞真是太酷了。
This is so cool.
I saw a fist fight on set once, too.
Really?
was crazy. It was so crazy.
Can you say the name of the movie?
I don't remember.
But yeah, it was this weird thing I did,
but it was out in the desert. Listen, guys.
这太棒了。我也在片场见过一次拳击斗殴。真的吗？太疯狂了。简直疯狂至极。你能说出那部电影的名字吗？我不记得了。但确实，那是我拍过的一部奇怪的作品，不过是在沙漠里拍的。听着，伙计们。
Was everyone wearing clothes? The point is, but I saw these
two dudes, these two big dudes, like a grip
and a gaffer get into it. They end up
they were arguing, and they ended up getting into a
fucking fist fight. Oh, wow. Well,
full circle moment, real quick as I want to give
KK. some shout out right now, but
he, if I was like, if I ever get to direct movies, I'm going to hire
大家当时都穿着衣服吗？重点是，我看到这两个家伙，两个大块头，一个灯光师和一个场务杠上了。他们争论着争论着，最后竟然打起了实架。哦，哇。好吧，说回正题，顺便借此机会向KK致敬，我当时想，如果我以后有机会当导演，我一定要雇佣
KK. Barrett, and he did my
movie outcome. He did. He was the production designer. So full circle, like 20 years later,
he was the greatest production designer ever, one of them for sure. So that was like a full circle
moment. It was like a dream of mine. So from there, you do a great job in that movie. You have to
wait until the movie comes out until the industry starts to see it, or does word get out
from like dailies and early cuts and stuff like that and gets you to... My part was so small
that like it didn't make a dent. It wasn't like people were like, you know, trying to give me jobs
and shit. And then
KK·巴雷特，而他确实参与了我的电影《结局》。他做到了。他就是美术指导。所以兜兜转转，大约20年后，他成了史上最伟大的美术指导之一，绝对是其中之一。所以这就像是一个完美的闭环。就像是我的一个梦想。从那以后，你在那部电影里表现得很棒。你得等到电影上映后整个行业才开始注意到你，还是说通过样片和早期剪辑之类的消息传开，才让你……我的戏份太少了，根本没掀起什么水花。大家并不是那种，你知道的，争着给我介绍工作的人。然后
I met a guy named Peter Principato
Incredible Manager, who is my former manager,
awesome dude. And he introduced
He was my former two. That's why I was looking
at Will, sorry. He was legend
and he got me an audition
for campus ladies and that was my
second job. Was
我遇到了一位名叫彼得·普林西帕托的了不起的经纪人，他是我以前的经纪人，超级棒的家伙。他介绍他以前也是我的。所以我才看着威尔，抱歉。他是传奇，他帮我争取到了《校园娇娃》的试镜机会，那是我的第二份工作。那是
campus ladies and I got like three or four
episodes on that and it was all
groundings people and on that show
because it was like Will Forte
and Meyer Rudolph and like
every dope person I was
like in love with came on to the show.
And then my life really kicked off
《校园娇娃》，我在里面拍了三四集，里面全都是The Groundlings剧团的演员，而且在那部剧里，因为有威尔·福特和玛娅·鲁道夫，基本上所有我迷恋的酷炫大咖都来客串了。然后我的人生真正迎来了起步
when I met Judd Apatow.
Right.
You know, so.
So did those people kind of get in Judd's ear
and say, hey, you got to check this guy out?
I think I was just starting to do like table reads.
I mean, this is like inside baseball,
so this might be so boring.
当我遇到贾德·阿帕图的时候。对吧。你知道的，所以。所以那些人在贾德耳边吹风了吗，说，嘿，你得去看看这小子？我想我当时才刚开始参与剧本围读。我是说，这听起来有点像业内黑话，所以可能会非常无聊。
Is this boring as shit?
Okay.
Right, so like when somebody's going to like has a script
and they're thinking about making a movie,
they'll get a bunch of really talented people around a table
and they'll read it out loud and see if it makes everybody laugh.
And that was like the funny, like 18-year-old.
There wasn't a lot of like 18,
这无聊透顶吗？好吧。对，所以当有人手里有个剧本并考虑拍成电影时，他们会找一群极具才华的人围坐在一张桌子旁，大声朗读剧本，看看能不能把大家逗笑。而我当时就像那个搞笑的、18岁的家伙。当时并没有多少18岁的……
me and Michael Sarah would be at like all of them together, you know?
So, and like Seth and Jason Siegel, like all the young dudes would be at them.
And then when Judd started blowing up, I auditioned for a four-year-old virgin.
I met him and Seth.
And then my life, from then on that day, I shot 40-year-old Virgin.
It's one scene in an eBay store.
And it was raining that day.
So we were only supposed to shoot that scene for like an hour, but it was raining.
我和迈克尔·塞拉几乎会参加所有的剧本围读，你知道的？所以，还有塞斯和杰森·席格尔，所有这些年轻的小伙子都会参加。后来随着贾德开始大红大紫，我去为《四十岁的老处男》试镜。我见到了他和塞斯。从那以后，从那一天的我的人生开始起飞，我拍摄了《四十岁的老处男》。我在一个eBay商店里只有一场戏。那天还下着雨。所以我们本来只需要拍那场戏大约一个小时，但外面在下雨。
So they didn't have a cover.
set. So we shot it a whole day and I just improvised a whole day in front of Judd and Seth and
Sean Robertson, one of my best friends. And Judd was like, what do you want to write? And I was like,
you don't understand all I want to do is right. And so, but what about the, so he gave me, I had a, I pitched
him two movies and he bought them. And my parents are like, who is this guy who's molesting you?
I was living at home and I was 19. They're like, who is Jud Abbotown? Is he like touching your
weiner because like you're like a fucking weird. Spitting a lot of time over that.
Stoner who like doesn't have a job and like why do you have a two-picture deal at like
因此他们没有备用棚。所以我们整整拍了一整天，我当着贾德、塞斯和我的挚友之一肖恩·罗伯逊的面即兴发挥了一整天。贾德当时问，你想写点什么？我说，你不明白，我满脑子只想写作。所以，但是关于那个，他给了我，我向他推销了两个剧本，他都买下了。我父母当时问，这个在对你进行猥亵的家伙到底是谁？我当时19岁，还跟父母住在一起。他们问，贾德·阿帕图是谁？他是不是在摸你的小鸡鸡，因为你看起来像个他妈的怪胎。把大量时间花在
universal and you're like it made no sense. What were the films?
One was called Middle Child which a lot of those jokes I won't say but the movie maybe got swallowed
into another movie. And then one called one was about an imaginary friend which is really clever
script and then neither of them got made. But it like ingratiated me with those guys and then
we went on this whole crazy, awesome journey.
I hear this all the time, like, just those two, like the title middle child and something
with imaginary friend with you writing it, where did those scripts go?
Like, why don't we resurrect them?
一个整天无所事事的瘾君子身上，为什么你在环球影业能签下两部电影的合约？这根本说不通。拍的是什么电影？其中一部叫《夹心饼干》，里面很多笑话我就不说了，不过这部电影可能被合并到另一部里了。还有一部讲的是关于一个想象中的朋友，这是一个非常聪明的剧本，但这两部电影最后都没拍成。不过这让我赢得了这帮人的欢心，接着我们就开启了一段疯狂而美妙的旅程。我经常听到这种说法，比如，仅仅是那两个片名，像《夹心饼干》以及那个关于想象中的朋友的剧本，都是你写的，那些剧本都去哪儿了？为什么不把它们重新翻拍出来？
They're around.
I mean, like, I could probably try and clean one up and get it made, but I have new new stuff.
What's that?
You want to take a look at it?
I'll just want to take a look.
I'll do the table read.
There's great hard for you.
Are you accepting notes still?
它们都还在呢。我是说，我大概可以试着修改润色一下然后把它拍成电影，不过我现在有新的项目了。什么？你想看看吗？我只是想看一眼。我可以参加剧本围读。这对你来说难度太大了。你现在还接受意见吗？
Because Sean, we'll be right back.
This episode of Smart List is sponsored by Ashley.
the brand that helped turn our live event stage
into a fully styled living space.
Ashley's whole thing is making your home feel like you
with styles that balance timeless design and modern trends.
Slower, Sean.
And it's not just about looks.
因为肖恩，我们马上回来。本期《聪明糊涂虫》节目由Ashley赞助播出。这个品牌将我们的现场活动舞台变成了一个全方位精心设计的起居空间。Ashley的核心理念是通过平衡永恒设计和现代潮流的风格，让你的家充满你的个人特色。慢一点，肖恩。这不仅仅关乎外观。
Their stuff is built to hold up to the real life
with durable materials and easy to clean fabric.
For the live show, we were on their Mod Max sofa.
It's modular so you can kind of move it around
however you want depending on your space.
And it's got that Super Soft Performance Fabriced.
which sounds fancy, but really just means if you spill something,
you're not immediately into panic, Sean.
他们的产品采用耐用材料和易清洗面料，能够经受现实生活的考验。在现场演出中，我们坐的是他们的Mod Max沙发。它是模块化的，所以你可以根据你的空间随心所欲地移动它。它还拥有超级柔软的高性能面料。这听起来很高档，但实际上只是意味着如果你不小心洒了东西，你也不会瞬间陷入恐慌，肖恩。
Yeah.
So the accent chairs were great, too.
Big, they're comfortable.
The kind of chair where you sit down and you go,
all right, I'm here for a while.
And the coffee and accent tables tied everything together.
Clean, simple, but somehow made everything feel finished.
It's just a beautiful setup.
是的。所以那些单人沙发也超棒。很大，很舒服。就是那种你一坐下来就会感叹，好吧，我要在这里待上一会儿的椅子。而咖啡桌和边几把整个空间完美地串联在了一起。干净、简约，但又不知怎么让一切都显得完美收官。这真是一个美丽的布置。
Honestly, that setup worked perfectly for the show.
The modular couch made it easy for us to fit
however many people ended up on stage.
Yeah, I mean, good luck with you, man.
Thanks.
I'm not kidding, I would have taken that whole setup home.
It looked great.
Felt very comfortable, you know?
说实话，这个布景跟节目绝配。模块化沙发让我们能轻松容纳任何最终登上舞台的人数。对，我是说，祝你好运，老兄。谢谢。说真的，我恨不得把整套布置都搬回家。看起来太棒了。坐着感觉非常舒服，你知道吗？
Really did feel like we were just hanging out in someone's living room.
Yeah, and for Jason, this is the farthest he's been from his couch in weeks.
It's hurtful.
Ashley is all about style that's made for real life with white glove delivery right to your room of choice.
Visit your local Ashley store or head to ashley.com to find your style.
This episode of SmartList is brought to you in part by Skinny Pop Popp.
Which, yes, is exactly what we were inhaling backstage at the live show.
True story.
真的感觉就像我们只是在某人的客厅里闲逛。是的，对杰森来说，这是他几周来离自己沙发最远的一次。这太伤人了。Ashley专注于为现实生活打造的风格，并提供送货上门并摆放到你指定房间的尊贵服务。访问你当地的Ashley门店或登录ashley.com寻找你的风格。本期《聪明糊涂虫》部分内容由Skinny Pop爆米花倾情赞助。没错，这正是我们在直播后台疯狂狂嗑的零食。真实的故事。
There is something very satisfying about a snack that actually delivers and doesn't come with a paragraph of ingredients.
Yeah, and Skinny Pop keeps it simple.
Real ingredients, classic popcorn.
Nothing weird.
Nothing you have to Google.
Yeah, the original is light and airy, but still hits the spot.
And if you want to mix it up, they got white cheddar, butter, sweet and salty kettle.
It's one of those snacks that works for anything.
有一种零食真的能完美满足你的口腹之欲，而且配料表简单得没有一长串化学成分，这感觉真的很棒。是的，Skinny Pop保持了配料的简单。真实的配料，经典的爆米花。没有什么奇怪的东西。没有什么需要你去谷歌搜索的东西。对，原味轻盈空灵，但依然直击灵魂。如果你想换个口味，他们还有白切达干酪、黄油、甜咸焦糖味。这绝对是一款适用于任何场合的零食。
Watching something, traveling, pretending, you're only going to have a handful.
Jason?
Jason, that's you.
We had Skinny Pop backstage at the live show, and it disappeared fast.
Families, friends, zero restrained.
Yeah, it's kind of our go-to, movie night road trip before we record during the record.
White cheddar, butter, sweet and salty kettle.
Sean, do you put Skinny Pop on your pasta marinar?
看节目、旅行、假装你只打算吃一小把。杰森？杰森，说的就是你。我们在直播后台准备了Skinny Pop，结果转眼就被抢光了。家人、朋友，完全没有任何克制力。对，这简直是我们的首选，看电影之夜、公路旅行、录制前以及录制期间必备。白切达干酪、黄油、甜咸焦糖味。肖恩，你会把Skinny Pop加到你的意面玛丽娜拉酱里吗？
Oh, absolutely.
It adds texture.
It's upsetting.
Look, the stuff we want to snack on and the stuff we should snack on, usually not the same thing.
Skinny Pop bridges that gap.
Creates a bridge in between the...
Skinny Pop.
Deliciously popped, perfectly salted, popular for a reason.
哦，当然会。它增加了口感。这太让人抓狂了。听着，我们想吃的零食和我们应该吃的零食，通常不是同一回事。Skinny Pop完美地弥补了这道鸿沟。在两者之间架起了一座桥梁……Skinny Pop。爆得美味，咸淡适中，大受欢迎是有原因的。
I'll say.
And now, back to the show.
Well, what about the stroke of genius luck that you landed in front of Judd Apatel,
like one of the greatest sort of finders of talent and nurturers of talent?
Yeah, he's amazing.
And giving people chances and championing them.
Like, look what he's done just, you alone.
I mean, and there's what?
我敢说。现在，让我们回到节目中。好吧，那你怎么看那种神来之笔般的运气，让你遇到了贾德·阿帕图，他简直是发掘人才和培养人才的最伟大推手之一？是的，他太棒了。他总是给新人机会并大力支持他们。比如，看看他所做的一切，光是你一个人。我是说，还有什么？
100, 100 people.
He's probably named 25 people right now
that are household names that Judd has championed.
He's incredible.
He's so...
He's up there with Lauren Michaels
as far as launching people into the comedy world.
Yeah, there was like me and my friends,
100个，100个人。他现在可能已经捧红了25个家喻户晓的名字，这些都是贾德一手提拔的。他太不可思议了。他简直……在将新人推向喜剧界方面，他完全可以和洛恩·迈克尔斯相提并论。对，当时有我和我的朋友们，
but then there's like Lena Dunham
and it went on like Amy Schumer.
You know, like he really just like
saw see something in these people
and he's so great at like mining
what you're going through
and helping you find your voice.
And what he really did was he put me through Harvard
但后来还有莉娜·杜汉姆，接着是艾米·舒默。你知道的，他真的能慧眼识珠看出这些人的潜力，而且他超级擅长挖掘你正在经历的内心波折并帮助你找到属于自己的声音。而他真正做到的，是让我经历了一场喜剧电影导演领域的哈佛级教育
education of directing comedy movies.
So, like, now that I'm 42
and we have our own company, shout out Strong Baby.
Shout out Matt Dynes, my bestie up there.
And we produce the movies we make now.
I like know what to do because of Judd.
You know, so I'd go, he was blowing up.
So my favorite thing was going to the table reads
。所以，现在我42岁了，我们有了自己的公司，向“强宝贝”致敬。向那边的我最好的朋友马特·戴恩斯致敬。我们现在自己制片拍电影。因为贾德的缘故，我知道该怎么做了。你知道的，所以我当时想去，他当时正当红。所以我最喜欢的事情就是去参加剧本围读
because you'd have writers at the table reads
and you dissect and give notes on the scripts.
And that's what I love to this day.
I love like the Rubik's Cube
of Crack.
and making better and making a comedy script better.
You're not burdened by the idea of writing.
I love it.
因为在剧本围读时会有编剧在场，你们会剖析剧本并提出修改意见。这就是我至今仍然热爱的事情。我喜欢喜剧魔方，喜欢把它拼好，让喜剧剧本变得更好。你不会被写作的理念所压垮。我太爱了。
It's my favorite part of the process.
But I mean, do you love the part where you're sitting in a room by yourself
and you're staring at a blank wall
and you're just trying to like, trying to fill a blank page?
Like to me, that's the hardest thing in the business.
As dick-headish and insane as I was when I got famous at like 22,
like, I don't take for granted a day that I get paid to write.
jokes. I actually
这是我整个过程中最喜欢的部分。但是，我是说，你喜欢那种独自坐在房间里盯着一面空白的墙，努力去填满一张空白页面的过程吗？对我来说，这才是这行里最难的事。尽管当年我在22岁左右成名时是个不可一世的混蛋、疯疯癫癫的，但我从不把每天拿薪水写笑话的日子视为理所当然。我甚至
think, and I've grown way past
that part when I was 21 or 22,
but like, I cannot
believe I get to write jokes for my job.
I say it to myself every
day. I'm like, dude, structure
and like character development and
you know, all is lost
觉得——我已经远远超越了21、22岁时的那个状态——但我简直不敢相信我的工作竟然是写笑话。我每天都在对自己说。我在想，老兄，结构、角色塑造，还有你知道的，在第75页遭遇绝境，以及所有这些你必须面对的东西……
on page 75 and like all of
this like stuff you've got to like
there's like...
It's the best job in the world. By the way,
Tony of you noticed, everything exhausts
them. Yeah. Everything.
Dude, if I was on smart list, I wouldn't fucking write screws.
No, it's so hard.
这是世界上最好的工作。顺便问一下，托尼你注意到了吗，每件事都能把他累个半死。对。每件事。老兄，如果我是“聪明糊涂虫”的嘉宾，我他妈才不写剧本呢。不，这太难了。
Don't you guys have like a mobile company?
Like, dude, if I was you guys, I wouldn't touch a computer the rest of my goddamn life.
I live in Tahiti and fucking phone this in on Zoom, dude.
All right.
I'm out here.
I got to work in Hollywood who's like, doesn't exist anymore.
I'm like, I'm basically a cobbler.
I make comedy movies with like me and two other people.
难道你们没有那种移动公司吗？老兄，如果我是你们，我余生绝对不会碰一下电脑。老兄，我会在塔希提岛生活，然后在Zoom上随便应付一下工作得了。好吧。我混迹于此。我得在好莱坞工作，这里的生态已经不复存在了。我心想，我基本上就是个修鞋匠。我和另外两个人一起制作喜剧电影。
Well, John, talk to talk.
me about that. I know you're half joking about
Hollywood being whatever you just said, like,
it's over, you know, because that's the feeling
out there right now is that, you know, where is this going?
And everybody's scared and everybody's like,
what's going to happen with AI?
And especially in comedy, not especially
好吧，乔纳，跟我们聊聊这个。我知道你刚才开玩笑说好莱坞怎么怎么样，说什么“结束了”，你知道的，因为现在大家普遍都有这种感觉，就是说，这行业到底要走向何方？每个人都很恐慌，大家都在想，人工智能会带来什么影响？尤其是喜剧界，倒也不是说特别在喜剧界，而是……
in comedy, but like... Oh, thank God a conversation
about AI.
Oh, finally.
Finally, we can hear some points.
You can put in a prompt that says,
write me a joke that Jonah Hill might
say on a stage with three other dudes.
Like, you'll get, like, six jokes.
哦，谢天谢地，终于开始讨论人工智能了。哦，太好了。终于能听到一些高见了。你可以输入一个提示词，写道：写一个乔纳·希尔可能会在舞台上跟其他三个家伙一起讲的笑话。然后你会得到大约六个笑话。
So, like, does that kind of, like, affect the whole writing stuff?
No, because you can't replace...
Comedy ultimately is human pain and time.
And then you're just plusing it, perhaps.
It'd be like having some Grom writers in the writer's room.
They'll write, I'll write, like, 50 shitty jokes that you could rewrite or something.
But they won't be...
They won't have the human experience that allows comedy to be funny,
所以，这会不会对整个写作行业造成影响？不会，因为你无法取代……喜剧的本质归根结底是人类的痛苦和时间。然后你可能只是在上面锦上添花。这就好比在编剧室里塞了几个笨蛋编剧。他们会写，我会写出大约50个烂笑话，你可以对它们进行重写什么的。但它们不会……它们不会具备让喜剧之所以好笑的人类真实体验，
because you got to get dumped
to write a funny movie
about getting dumped, right?
A computer hasn't been dumped.
They know,
maybe they have, I don't know, I shouldn't say that.
I'm sorry to all the computers in the crowd
and, but like, I don't worry at all.
因为你必须经历被甩，才能写出一部关于被甩的好笑电影，对吧？计算机可从来没被甩过。它们知道吗，也许它们经历过，我不知道，我不该这么说。我向在座的所有计算机道歉，但是，我一点也不担心。
I also live in, I'm like, I just go until they fire me.
Like, I'm so motivated by what I do and my family
that, like, I just have two things.
I have my family and,
writing comedy.
Yeah, yeah.
So, like...
Well, where do I fit in in that?
而且我的生活态度是，我就这么一直干下去，直到他们炒我鱿鱼。我是被我的事业和我的家庭所驱使的，所以，我只有两样东西。我有我的家庭和喜剧创作。对，对。所以，像……
Yeah.
Well, I'm here tonight.
All right, so how close are we to Superbad now at this point in...
It'll be 20 years...
Oh, you mean, like, at that point in this...
Yeah, in this story here where you're...
Oh, dude, so is 40-year-old Virgin, and then a year later we made Knocked Up, and then two months
after knocked up, we made Super Bad.
那我在这其中扮演什么角色？
So, like, a year after I met Judd, we made Super Bad.
So who...
I'm embarrassed.
I should know this.
And you guys were working with Michael, right around them, too.
Who wrote Superbad?
Super Bad.
Seth Rogan and Evan Goldberg
是的。好吧，我今晚就在这儿。好了，那么在故事的这个阶段，我们离《太坏了》还有多远……那将是20周年……哦，你的意思是，在这段经历的那个阶段……是的，在这个你……哦，老兄，所以是《四十岁的老处男》，然后一年后我们拍了《一夜大肚》，然后在《一夜大肚》两个月后，我们拍了《太坏了》。
wrote the most brilliant script
of all the time.
Yeah.
And it read,
we all improvised
and everyone comes up
with great jokes on those movies,
but their script that they wrote
所以，在我认识贾德大约一年后，我们拍了《太坏了》。那谁……我很尴尬。我本该知道这事的。而且你们当时也和迈克尔合作过，对吧？谁写的《太坏了》？《太坏了》是塞斯·罗根和埃文·戈德堡
was, like, flawless.
Yeah.
But like, do you remember
Michael Sarah going away
to do that movie
that was done during the hiatus?
No, but I tell you something,
this is a true story.
写出了史上最才华横溢的剧本。是的。读起来确实如此，我们在拍那些电影时都进行了即兴发挥，每个人都会想出很棒的笑话，但他们写出的剧本
So years ago, right before,
like the year before Super Bad,
there was a script
that we were going to do
at a place.
I won't say,
because then you'll be able to know who is in charge.
And it was about, it's this crazy, great script
简直是无懈可击。是的。但是，你还记得迈克尔·塞拉当时离开去拍那部在档期空隙完成的电影吗？不记得，不过我告诉你一件事，这是一个真实的故事。
that Mitch Hurwitz and I worked on with Jim Valli.
Really, really, really funny.
It turned out great.
And I said to the guy who ran this particular studio,
so this is, Superbad was 2007, right?
Jesus.
I mean, pause for a second.
You with the dates.
所以多年前，就在《太坏了》上映前的那一年，有一个剧本我们打算在一个地方拍。我就不说是哪了，因为那样你就会知道是谁在掌权了。那是关于，这是一个疯狂而伟大的剧本，
He knows dates like Mary Lee Leonard.
That is crazy.
It's great.
Yeah.
And he'll tell you what month was the film released in?
Which one?
Super bad.
2007.
米奇·赫威茨和我以及吉姆·瓦利一起合作的。真的非常、非常搞笑。结果非常棒。我对管理这家特定制片厂的家伙说——所以这是，《太坏了》是2007年上映的，对吧？天哪。我是说，停顿一下。你可真懂日期。
Oh, that I don't know.
I don't know.
It was 2007.
Yeah, no.
It's probably a summer release, right?
Yeah, probably.
It might have been.
But I remember going in, and this thing that we were working on called for this dude, this character I was playing, and then these two teenage sons.
他记得日期简直就像玛丽·露·亨纳一样。太疯狂了。太棒了。对。而且他还会告诉你电影是哪个月上映的？哪部？《太坏了》。2007年。
And it was two teenage boys who were best friends.
It was basically like a three-hander.
And I said to the guy, this is before all that, before 40-year-old virgin, I go,
It should be Michael Sarah and this kid, Jonah Hill.
No way.
And he goes, what?
No, man.
What are you talking about?
哦，那个我真不知道。我不知道。是2007年。对，没错。可能是暑期档上映的吧？对，有可能。也许是吧。但我记得我走进去时，我们当时在筹备的那个项目需要这样一个家伙，也就是我演的角色，然后还有两个十几岁的儿子。
And I swear to God, and a fucking year later or whatever it was, 18 months later,
Super Bad comes out.
And it's like a huge hit.
And I'm like, this dumb fuck.
This fucking guy blew it.
And he got fired.
Did he?
You should have.
那是两个十几岁的男孩，是最好的朋友。基本上可以说是三个人的对手戏。我对那个家伙说——这还是在这一切发生之前，《四十岁的老处男》之前——我说，应该让迈克尔·塞拉和这个叫乔纳·希尔的小孩来演。不可能。他问，什么？不，老兄。你在说什么呢？
That's crazy.
I'll tell you after.
Thank you.
And then you're going to be like, yeah.
Because when I met Will, like when I was 18, I met him at my friend's house,
and I was bugging out, dude, because he was Job from Arrested Development.
I was like, holy shit, dude.
我向上帝发誓，就在他妈的一年后还是什么时候，18个月后，《太坏了》上映了。结果成了一部超级大热门。当时我就想，这个大笨蛋。这个王八蛋把事情搞砸了。然后他被炒了。真的吗？他活该。
So good.
Couldn't believe it.
These guys.
Anyway.
All right, so Superbad happens.
That's very, very cool, very exciting, yes, but I would imagine.
He was game changing, too.
That movie.
太疯狂了。我待会儿告诉你。谢谢。我待会儿告诉你。然后你就会觉得，没错。因为当我遇到威尔时，我18岁的时候，我在朋友家遇到了他，我当时整个人都惊呆了，老兄，因为他在《发展受阻》里演戈布。我当时想，卧槽，老兄。
That's my question.
Was it disruptive?
Or did you flow with it pretty good?
because I know Michael Sarah was,
because Arrested Development was...
Just finished, right?
We were just done,
Arrested Development.
太棒了。简直不敢相信。这些家伙。不管怎样。好吧，所以《太坏了》大获成功。这非常、非常酷，非常令人兴奋，是的，不过我猜……那部电影也具有颠覆性。
We had finished the three seasons at Fox?
Yeah, because we finished in December of 2005.
Okay, so then that...
Are you allowed to say Rain Man?
I remember...
He is, Mary Lou Hennar.
Are we okay, okay, no.
I remember Michael was just...
这是我的问题。它具有颠覆性吗？还是你很顺利地顺应了这股潮流？因为我记得迈克尔·塞拉当时，因为《发展受阻》……刚刚结束，对吧？我们当时刚拍完《发展受阻》。
Even though he'd already had some fame,
some notoriety from...
and Rested Development. Superbad was a whole other level.
And there was a level
of adjustment for him, I know,
for sure. For you as well?
Was it comfortable for a bit?
I mean, it was exciting as
我们在福克斯拍完了三季？对，因为我们在2005年12月拍完了。好吧，所以那……你们能提《雨人》吗？我记得……他果然是玛丽·露·亨纳。我们没事，好吧，不。我记得迈克尔当时……
hell, but it was crazy. It was just
bizarre, you know, it was like...
Can't walk down the street anymore.
Yeah, and Michael and I hung out every day still.
So we would go to Cantors.
I lived behind Cantors in Cecil Department,
and Michael and I would just walk to Canters
and people would be talking
尽管他凭借《发展受阻》已经有了一定名气和知名度。但《太坏了》完全是另一个量级。我知道，对他来说确实有一个适应期。你也是吗？有一段时间觉得很不习惯吗？我的意思是，那简直
about the shit, like our lives,
were like that movie,
and people would see us,
and they'd freak out
because it's like we walked off the screen
into the deli.
You know, like...
People think you're shooting a sequel.
刺激得要命，但也很疯狂。简直匪夷所思，你知道的，就好像……再也不能走在街上了。是的，而且我和迈克尔当时依然每天都在一起鬼混。所以我们会去坎托熟食店。我就住在塞西尔大街坎托熟食店的后面，我和迈克尔会步行去坎托熟食店，然后人们就会开始议论那些事，就好像我们的生活就像那部电影一样，人们看到我们，就会吓得大惊小怪，因为感觉就像是我们直接从银幕里走进了熟食店。你知道的，就像……
Yeah, it was just so bizarre, you know, it was trippy.
But are you thinking, because you're,
how old are you at that point?
20?
22.
So you're at an age...
I'm not Will, 22 or 23.
人们以为你们在拍续集。
So you're at an age
where you're thinking about,
okay, I need to have a job,
a career, I need to be starting thinking
five years, ten years in the future.
I got to provide.
So this is, are you thinking
now this is, I've got some
是的，简直太匪夷所思了，你知道的，太魔幻了。但你当时在想，因为你，你那时候多大？20岁？22岁。22岁。所以你处于那个年纪……我可不是威尔，22岁或23岁。
momentum, this can be my career.
Does it align with what your plans
were, what your dreams were, what your goals were?
I
was obviously stoked
because I loved the movie.
I didn't know if I'd get to work on shit
I loved. I knew I'd work in comedy
所以你处于那种开始考虑“好吧，我需要一份工作、一份事业，我需要开始考虑未来五年、十年的规划”的年纪。我得养家糊口。所以，你当时是不是在想，现在这就是……我积攒了一些势头，这可以成为我的职业。这符合你的计划、你的梦想、你的目标吗？我当时显然兴奋极了，因为我太喜欢那部电影了。我当时不知道自己是否还能参演我真正喜欢的作品。我知道自己会从事喜剧行业，
in some capacity. Like I had the confidence
enough to know like, I
I am professionally funny,
even at, like, 18 or 19, whatever.
But I didn't, like, Superbad was, like, my dream.
I was, like, what I wanted to see.
Yeah, right.
You know, so I was so stoked that Judd was in the position
在某种程度上。因为我有足够的自信知道，我是一个专业的搞笑人才，哪怕是在18岁或19岁的时候，无论怎样。但我并没有……《太坏了》简直就是我的梦想。我当时就觉得，这正是我想要创作的作品。对，没错。你知道的，所以我太兴奋了，贾德当时正处于能够拍摄那种类型电影的位置上。这些电影正在被拍出来。《太坏了》上映了。你心里很清楚这事成了。这是一部超级大热片。简直疯狂。我要去看那部电影。喜剧故事曾是一门大生意。
to make the kind of movie.
Those films are being made.
Superbad comes out.
You've got a pretty good idea that shit's working out.
It's a huge head.
It was crazy.
I'm going to watch that.
Comedy features were a huge business.
啊？我今晚就要看。我是说，我看过，但我还要再看一遍。拍完《发展受阻》之后。是的。现在我有了孩子，现在我有孩子了，我心想，天哪，想象一下当我的儿子——他才三岁——想象一下他看那部电影的场景。
Huh?
I'm going to watch it tonight.
I mean, I've seen it, but I'm going to watch it again.
Right after arrested.
Yeah.
Now that I have kids, now that I have kids, I'm like, oh my God,
imagine when my son, like, who's three,
like imagine him watching that movie.
天哪。我以前从来没想过这破事。梅贝尔很喜欢。梅贝尔，老兄，你的那些酷小孩现在还会看吗？她很喜欢。没错。她今晚来这里感到非常兴奋。是的。
Oh my God.
I never thought about that shit.
Maple loved it.
Maple, dude, does your cool kids still watch it and stuff?
She loved it.
That's right.
She was very excited to be here tonight.
Yeah.
我其实想知道的是，乔纳，那简直太疯狂了。简直是精神错乱。就像，我们根本没法到处走动。那种感觉既让人兴奋又有点吓人。
What I kind of want to know is, John,
but it was psycho.
It was psycho.
Like, we couldn't walk around.
And it was, like, so exciting and kind of scary.
and then like you just cannot not become obsessed with yourself
when something like that happens.
It just is like it's impossible not to become like a weird dude for like a year.
而且当那种事情发生时，你根本不可能不开始变得极度自恋。那种情况下，有那么一年时间，你几乎不可能不变成一个行为古怪的家伙。
Everybody's telling you you're great, right?
So everybody's going, you're the greatest.
You just have all your friends that you're still friends with from high school,
but all of a sudden one of you people like respect and pay attention to.
So like you just are kind of a self-centered person
because it's about you a lot of the time.
Yeah.
And thank God that time is over and it's not about me anymore.
每个人都对你说你太棒了，对吧？所以每个人都在说，你是最伟大的。你身边只有那些你从高中起就一直保持联系的朋友，但突然之间，所有人开始尊重你并对你格外关注。所以你不知不觉就变成了一个以自我为中心的人，因为很多时候镜头都聚焦在你身上。是的。谢天谢地，那段时光已经过去了，现在生活不再仅仅围绕着我转了。
Yeah.
But you're skipping over a very interesting part where you're like,
you're kind of,
you're munching on all the junk food of all that fame
and all of that access and relevance and whatnot.
And then you start to think, this is a question,
what should I do about dramatic work to make sure that I...
Oh, so I'll tell you the smartest thing I did was, like, Michael,
是的。但你跳过了非常有趣的一部分，就是你在贪婪地享受名气带来的所有垃圾食品，以及所有的特权、热度和诸如此类的事情。然后你开始思考，这是一个问题，我该如何对待正剧表演，以确保我……哦，那我告诉你我做过最聪明的事是什么，就像迈克尔一样，
Michael had Juno come out like two months later.
What a movie.
He was like Michael Jackson, dude.
Have you seen Juno?
But for real.
Michael Sarah had Super Bad and Juno come out in like six months.
And it was like, he really, he was more famous than I was.
And he retreated inward.
迈克尔在大约两个月后上映了《朱诺》。多棒的一部电影啊。他当时就像迈克尔·杰克逊一样，老兄。你看过《朱诺》吗？但说真的。迈克尔·塞拉在六个月内连续推出了《太坏了》和《朱诺》。那感觉就像是，他真的比我还红。而他却选择了内敛退隐。
And I was like, I'm going to watch Juno tonight too.
The best movie about the last video we'll ever see.
Michael Sarah went to inward?
Soft spoken and inward?
But he is still, I will say to this,
he is top three best friends in the world to this day.
A great man.
We still talk like once a week.
当时我想：我今晚也要重温《朱诺》。这是我们看过的关于最后一卷录像带的最棒的电影。迈克尔·塞拉选择了内敛？说话轻声细语又内敛？但直到今天，我依然要说，他是全世界我最好的三个朋友之一。一个伟大的男人。我们至今仍保持着每周一次的通话。
Just finish directing a movie.
Yeah, he's imposed on his movie.
It's going to be amazing.
He's so fucking brilliant and cool and a great human being.
And, but what I did was I got offered a bunch of movies for the first time.
All in the comedy space?
All the comedies, yeah.
I was like, I can't make a, none of these are as good as super bad.
刚刚导演完一部电影。对，他的电影正在后期制作中。肯定会超级棒。他太他妈才华横溢、太酷了，而且是一个伟大的人。但是，我当时做的是，我平生第一次收到了许多电影的邀约。全都是喜剧片吗？全都是喜剧片，对。当时我想，我拍不了，这些片子没有一部能比得上《太坏了》。
Right.
So I said, to my agent, what writing jobs are available?
And Sasha Baron Cohen was looking for writers for the Bruno movie.
And I auditioned for the writer's room.
How does that go?
What's the writer audition like?
It's like you get like a day sit-in in the writer's room.
But I had been in the writer's rooms with Judd in those guys.
所以我就对我的经纪人说，有什么编剧工作吗？当时萨莎·拜伦·科恩正在为《布鲁诺》电影寻找编剧。我去编剧室进行了试镜。过程是怎样的？编剧试镜是什么样的？就像是让你去编剧室旁听一天。但我之前和贾德他们一起待过编剧室。
So I got the job and I was like super, I was like arguably more famous than Sasha.
it was at that time.
And I was like a pimply writer
in his writer's room for like six months.
I would ride my bike to the lot over here
on Formosa from my apartment on Fairfax.
And people would be like, yo!
And I would just go and write jokes
所以我就得到了这份工作，我当时超级……我当时在名气上可以说比萨莎还要大。但我在他的编剧室里当了大约六个月满脸青春痘的底层编剧。我每天骑着自行车从费尔法克斯的公寓出发，去福莫萨街这里的片场。人们会喊：哟！而我只是去写笑话，
because I didn't want to think about like the outside world.
I didn't want to think about the pressure of like,
what do I do next?
That's such a funny move to do that.
To go from that to then all of a sudden
just to be a staff writer on the Bruno movie.
It was the best time, though, man.
Because it was like,
因为我不想去想外面的世界。我不想去想诸如“我下一步该做什么”之类的工作压力。做那种决定简直太有趣了。从那种高度突然转变成《布鲁诺》电影的一名普通编剧。不过那真的是一段最棒的时光，老兄。因为当时我就觉得，
I was like, I just got to work with one of my heroes and pitched like, I loved Bruno.
Like when the Allie G show came out, it was like, it was like when Arrested Development came out.
I was like obsessed with Bruno.
So like all of a sudden I was writing jokes and like Mickey Mouse was saying my jokes.
Like, you know, it wasn't just like someone cool.
It was like a character that I already loved.
He was an incredible talent.
Yeah, he's an awesome guy.
我终于能和我的偶像之一合作了，还能提出想法——我太喜欢《布鲁诺》了。当《阿里·G秀》问世时，那感觉就像《发展受阻》问世一样。我当时对《布鲁诺》痴迷得不得了。所以突然之间，我写出了笑话，然后连米老鼠都在说我写的笑话。你知道的，那可不仅仅是什么酷盖。那是一个我本就深爱的角色。他是个不可思议的天才。是的，他是个了不起的家伙。
He was an awesome boss.
I kind of want to get to.
I think you were trying to get to.
but man, you take a long time.
No, I do.
You're allowed to.
You're supposed to be speaking.
We want to hear from you.
他是个极好的老板。我其实想切入正题。我想你刚才也一直在试图切入，但老兄，你铺垫的时间太长了。不，确实长。你有这个权力。你本来就该多说。我们都想听你讲。
Dave, am I being boring or no?
No, no.
No.
No, this is this fascinating?
We love Jonah.
Sean, is this one of your favorite episodes?
We love.
Do we flip over to like Dax's podcast, Sean?
大卫，我很无聊吗？还是怎么着？不，不。不，这不是很迷人吗？我们太爱乔纳了。肖恩，这是你最喜欢的剧集之一吗？我们太爱了。我们要不要切到戴克斯的播客去，肖恩？
Or no, do we keep listening to this?
Fast forward.
I want to, Joan, I want to get into it,
because then you go and you start doing interesting things like Wolf of Wall Street,
in which you're amazing.
Thank you.
You're so, dude.
Don't skip over Moneyball.
还是说，不，我们要继续听这个？快进。乔纳，我想切入正题，因为接下来你去尝试了一些非常有趣的作品，比如《华尔街之狼》，你在里面的表演惊艳绝伦。谢谢。你太牛了，老兄。别跳过《点球成金》。
Well, I'll tell you this.
By the way, Moneyball.
Oh, dude.
Moneyball, first of all,
really hard film to make from that book
is a great book.
And I remember thinking, like,
they'll never do it.
好吧，那我告诉你这个。顺便说一句，《点球成金》。哦，老兄。《点球成金》首先是一部根据伟大小说改编而极难搬上银幕的电影。我记得当时想，他们绝对拍不成。
So far, that movie's so great.
You are so great in that movie.
So you do Moneyball.
Well, can I say one thing before that?
Yes, please.
I don't want to jump straight to there.
Did we miss the credit?
Let the guest talk, Will?
到目前为止，那部电影实在太棒了。你在那部电影里表现得太出色了。所以你演了《点球成金》。好吧，在那之前我能说一件事吗？好的，请说。我不想直接跳到那个阶段。我们漏掉功劳了吗？让嘉宾多说会儿话行吗，威尔？
I know the question.
I'm trying to get to it, dude.
The question you're trying to ask is this, in my opinion,
is this, is that
I got, I was working for Sasha and got off.
offered all the big comedies.
And I got offered the hangover and Cyrus at the same time.
And I did Cyrus.
我知道那个问题。我正试图切入呢，老兄。在我看来，你想问的问题其实是这样的：我当时在为萨莎工作，然后收到了所有大喜剧片的邀约。我同时收到了《宿醉》和《赛勒斯》的片约。而我选择了《赛勒斯》。
Wow.
And this is why we need agents.
I wish I did both.
Because the hangover rifts and is an amazing movie and I love Todd.
But like, I was like.
Cyrus didn't suck.
The two classes know what they're doing.
No, no, no.
哇。这就是我们需要经纪人的原因。我真希望两部都拍。因为《宿醉》系列爆火而且是一部了不起的电影，我也很喜欢托德。但当时我觉……《赛勒斯》其实也不赖。这两个班底都知道自己在干什么。不，不，不。
But it changed my life because I wanted to do dramatic movies and comedic movies.
And that script and that part was incredibly and very deep in a moment.
and a lot like my work today.
And guess what?
Bennett Miller probably saw Cyrus and he probably
did not see hangover. So he saw
Cyrus and he cast me
in Moneyball. That's amazing. Let him
但这彻底改变了我的人生，因为我既想拍剧情片，也想拍喜剧片。那个剧本和那个角色在当时极其具有深度，而且很符合我今天的创作方向。你猜怎么着？贝尼特·米勒可能看过《赛勒斯》，但他大概率没看过《宿醉》。所以他看了《赛勒斯》，然后选角让我出演了《点球成金》。这太惊艳了。让他
speak, dude. Sorry, I get so excited.
Now we're caught up. I'm just bridging the
just doing a little bridge. A little bridge work.
So then you work
Benet Miller and then you work with Martin Scorsese
on Wolf of Wall Street
and with Leo DiCaprio. That must
have been just a mind blow
把话说完，老兄。抱歉，我太激动了。现在我们言归正传。我只是在做个过渡，搭个小桥。做点过渡工作。所以接下来你和贝尼特·米勒合作，然后又和马丁·斯科塞斯合作了《华尔街之狼》，还搭档了莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥。第一天进组时，那绝对是脑洞大开的体验吧。
with the first day.
Well, Moneyball was unbelievable, man.
Moneyball was such a trip because, like, I remember my dad was a fan of that book,
and he's like, how are they going to make this?
Michael Lewis.
Yeah, how are you going to make this a movie?
Didn't Aaron Sorkin write that script?
And Steve Zalien.
好吧，《点球成金》简直不可思议，老兄。《点球成金》是一次太魔幻的经历，因为，我记得我爸是那本书的粉丝，他当时说，他们到底怎么把这拍成电影？迈克尔·刘易斯。是的，你怎么能把它拍成电影？难道不是阿伦·索尔金写的剧本吗？还有史蒂夫·扎利安。
I mean, Bennett Miller is not like a household name, but if you make films, he is.
He is such a brilliant director, the director of that film.
He's a movie.
That dude hasn't made a movie in years, right?
Since Foxcatcher, I think, right?
Yeah, since Foxcatcher.
And he's an amazing guy on top of me so much.
But didn't you want to direct early, early on?
我是说，贝尼特·米勒虽然不是家喻户晓的名字，但如果你拍电影，你就会知道他。他是如此才华横溢的导演，那部电影的导演。他可是个大导演。那家伙已经好几年没拍电影了吧？自从《狐狸猎手》以后，对吧？是的，自《狐狸猎手》以来。而且抛开才华不谈，他也是个极好的人，对我帮助太大了。但你不是在很早很早以前就想当导演吗？
So all these guys, I would just work for them
and sponge for them and write for them.
And, like, Spike, at that time,
I would just write for him for free for, like, five years,
whatever commercial, whatever, like short film he was doing
or whatever I'd help on
because I was just an intern for all these great directors
that I'd get the chance to work with as an actor.
所以所有这些导演，我就是去为他们打工，像海绵一样汲取他们的养分，为他们写剧本。而且，斯派克当时，我甚至会免费为他写五年剧本，无论是他正在制作的什么商业广告、短片还是其他项目，只要我作为演员有幸参与其中，我都会去帮忙，因为我就是所有这些伟大的导演手下的实习生。
And then also the comedy writers,
I was, like, such a nerd where I'd meet someone
who wrote on a rest of development.
and geek out over them at the mall
and they'd be like, what?
You know?
So it was, I'm so privileged
because I just love
还有那些喜剧编剧，我当时简直是个狂热的书呆子，以至于我在商场里遇到一个《发展受阻》的编剧时，会激动得像个极客一样冲上去跟人家大聊特聊，对方则会一脸懵地问：啊？你知道吗？所以，我真的觉得自己太特权了，因为我就是纯粹热爱
the actual work of what I do.
Right.
You know?
So then talk about that.
That's a rare-ass thing, you know?
Yeah, I mean, you're so incredibly lucky
to have been on the sets of all these incredible directors.
You find yourself cherry-picking from them.
我所从事的实际工作本身。对吧？你知道吗？那接着聊聊这个。这可是极其罕见的事，你知道的？是的，我是说，能参与所有这些伟大导演的片场，你真的极其幸运。你会发现自己在他们身上精挑细选、吸取精华。
But then Marty's like another level.
He's another level than everybody ever.
I feel like there's a bit of a paternal
element there between the two. You guys
seem so close and it's warm,
it's genuine. He did a great cameo
in the last film.
Yeah, he was in Outcome, which is on Apple, if you want to watch it.
但马丁简直是另一个层面的存在。他比以往任何人都高出好几个层面。我觉得你们两人之间似乎有一种父子般的默契。你们看起来那么亲密，温暖而真诚。他在你上一部电影里还客串了一个很棒的角色。对，他客串了《结局》，目前在苹果平台上播映，如果你想看的话。
Great movie. Keanu Reeves.
American Treasure.
Yep.
But yeah, the fact that I call Marty
and don't have to stop and like apologize
is psychotic to me, you know?
Like, Simpsons and Goodfellas, I guess, would just be
the two things that I think are like,
很棒的电影。基努·里维斯。美国国宝。没错。但是，我竟然能直接打电话给马丁，而不需要停顿下来先道个歉，这对我来说简直疯狂，你知道吗？就像，如果要把我的大脑拿出来冷冻然后剖开的话，《辛普森一家》和《好F家伙》，我想大概就是这两样东西。所以，你知道的，我居然能执导他。这是他给我的第一部电影。你给他提过意见吗？哈？你有给他提过意见吗？在任何时候？振作点，马克。你们会不会说，振作点。时间就是金钱，老兄。不，我是说，他来的时候准备得太充分了。老实说，整件事简直太迷幻了，他来到片场，而我来导演他。这种感觉简直充满迷幻色彩。就像分娩一样。就像你会看到各种绚丽的色彩，然后你会想：这太魔幻了。而且，呃……
if you had to like take my brain
and freeze it, you'd cut it open. It'd probably be those
two things. And so like, so, you know, I got to direct him. This was the first movie he gave.
Did you give him a note? Huh? Did you give him a note? At any point? Get your shit together,
Mark. You guys like, get your shit together. Time is money, man. No, I mean, like, he came in so
prepared. It was honestly, the whole thing was so psychedelic, like, him coming to set and me directing
him. It was so psychedelic. It was like childbirth. It was like, you see like colors and you're like,
this is so trippy. And, um, but
后来他为《采访》杂志采访了我，他不得不跟我聊聊这部电影。他很喜欢这部电影。而我也导演过另外两部电影，他虽然觉得还行，但并没有那么喜欢。他说，我喜欢，他觉得：这是一个巨大的飞跃，我非常喜欢这部电影。这对我意义重大。这真的太有力量了。虽然影评人并不同意。但是，你知道的，我在电影的前四分钟里都是在马桶上出场的，所以倒也有这么回事。
Then he interviewed me for Interview Magazine, and he had to talk to me about the movie.
And he loved the movie.
And I'm directed to two other movies, which he liked, but he didn't love.
And he was like, I love, he's like, this is a giant leap forward, and I love this movie.
And that meant a lot to me.
That was fucking so powerful.
The critics did not agree.
But, you know, I am introduced on the toilet for the first four minutes of the movie, so there's that.
不过，能让他喜欢这部电影简直太酷了。太他妈酷了，而且意义重大。他绝对是个最好的人。你和他合作完之后会经历戒断反应，因为你不得不和之后遇到的那些可怜的不幸的其他导演合作，根本无法与他相提并论。无论那些导演多么优秀、准备多么充分、多么惊艳。有没有一件事对你来说更深刻？
But, you know, to have him love the movie was fucking rad.
It was fucking cool and meant a lot.
And he's just the best guy.
You go through withdrawal after you work with him
because the poor unfortunate other directors you have to work with after
cannot compare it.
No matter how wonderful, prepared, and amazing they are.
Is there one thing that is louder to you
但是，你知道的，能让他喜欢这部电影真是酷毙了。太酷了，意义重大。而且他真的是最好的人。跟他合作完后你会经历戒断期，因为之后你不得不合作的那些不幸的其他导演根本无法与之相比。不管他们多么优秀、准备多么充分、多么惊艳。对你来说，有没有一件事声音更大
about the experience of working with him
that is different than other directors?
Is it just ease on set?
Nothing comes within a billion.
miles.
A billion with a B.
What is the one main thing
do you think that he does different?
关于与他合作的体验，有什么与众不同的地方吗？仅仅是在片场比较轻松吗？完全没有可比性。那是无可比拟的。你觉得他最主要的不同之处在哪里？
The most obvious thing to him.
Present company excluded, right?
So you know how he's everyone's favorite director?
Yeah.
So his ideology and taste in life and everything
is like your favorite person.
So it's like, he doesn't just,
director's work is like their worldview.
最显而易见的一点。在座的各位除外，对吧？你知道他是所有人的最爱导演吗？对。所以他人生的意识形态、品味以及一切，就像你最喜欢的人一样。所以这就好比，导演的工作不仅仅是工作，它就像是他们的世界观。
So the reason you love Marty's work is because you love him.
Right.
You love his.
lens as he sees the world through and like his taste his taste his humor his fucking realness as you know
like you see someone in life here's i know i know i'll be friends with somebody when you're like at the
mall and you see someone and the person's being a fucking weirdo and you look to like the person you're
with and you both see it without saying anything yeah marty sees the fucking weirdo that you see he gets it
right he sees it all even though he's and he's martin scorzi at the same time right you know like he's as human and real
所以你喜欢马丁作品的原因，是因为你喜欢他。对吧。你喜欢他的视角，他看世界的视角，还有他的品味，他的幽默感，他那该死的真实感，你知道的，就像你在生活中遇到某个人——我知道，我知道，我知道我什么时候会和某人成为朋友，当你在商场里，你看到一个人，那个人在做出那种极其古怪的举动，然后你看着和你在一起的人，你们两个不用说话就都注意到了。没错，马丁一眼就能看出你看到的那个怪胎，他懂的，对吧？他什么都看得出来，尽管他是，而且他同时还是马丁·斯科塞斯，对吧？你知道的，他既有人情味又真实
is like, the fuck is that guy doing?
And he's also the biggest genius you've ever met.
You're so...
We're all so lucky to be immersed into the thing
that we chose to do because we love to do it, right?
And you've been...
enjoyed tremendous success,
both writing and acting and now directing and everything.
就像，那家伙到底在干嘛？而他同时也是你见过的最大的天才。你们真的是……我们所有人都如此幸运，能够全身心投入到我们热爱并选择去从事的事情中，对吧？而你一直……取得了巨大的成功，无论是编剧、表演，还是现在的导演等等。
Is there something...
And that really stimulates your mind.
Like you said, there's my family and there's work, right?
And that's all you care about.
It's all you love.
Is there anything else...
I mean, I have friends.
Swear to God.
有没有什么……这真的很激发你的思维。就像你说的，我有家庭，还有工作，对吧？这就是你在乎的一切。这就是你所热爱的一切。还有别的吗……我是说，我有朋友。向上帝发誓。
Jason is my actual friend.
Great friend.
Yeah, yeah.
He is an amazing friend.
For sure.
Say more.
And I look up to him very much.
He's a, I would call him a mentor because I admire his relationship with his amazing wife, Amanda,
杰森是我真正的朋友。好朋友。对，对。他是个了不起的朋友。肯定的。多说点。我非常敬仰他。他是个——我会称他为导师，因为我钦佩他与他美丽的妻子阿曼达的关系，
and the father he is to his children.
And he's great at his job.
And they don't have to be mutually exclusive.
Let's hear it for Jason.
Yeah, it's true.
He's a wonderful human being.
It is, is very true.
He's got to go to New York tomorrow.
以及他作为父亲对孩子们的关爱。他在工作中表现出色。这两者并不排斥。为杰森喝彩。对，没错。他是个绝佳的人。确实如此。他明天得去纽约。
I don't know if you heard of what he's up against.
Yeah.
It's just, he's going to be humping it in 36J.
Do you send me the intro you wrote?
Yeah.
I'd love to read it.
I kind of remembered it.
It was pretty close to that.
我不知道你是否听说他将面对什么。是的，他要在36J座位上受罪了。你把你写的开场白发给我了吗？对。我很想读读。我大概还记得。跟那个差不太多。
I interrupted you.
What was your question, Sean?
No idea.
I'm sorry.
No, no, no.
Oh, no, no, I mean, being immersed so deeply immersed in what we'd love to do,
there's got to be other things that interest you.
Like, I'm obsessed with space.
我打断你了。肖恩，你的问题是什么来着？完全不记得了。对不起。不，不，不。哦，不，不，我的意思是，既然如此深深地沉浸在我们热爱的事业中，一定还有其他事情能引起你的兴趣。比如，我痴迷于太空。
Yes.
And sci-fi and all that.
What are the other things that when we think of Jonah Hill, instead of work and family,
what is the thing that's like, oh, you know what?
It's skateboarding.
What is the other thing that we're like, what?
I didn't know that.
You absolutely love.
是的。还有科幻等等。当人们想到乔纳·希尔时，除了工作和家庭，还有什么是那种会让人觉得“哦，你知道吗？是滑板”的事情？还有什么是会让我们觉得“什么？我不知道这个”并且你绝对热爱的事物？
Super great question, because hobbies are a huge part of my life and happiness as well.
So, like, I love Brazilian jihitsu.
I love, except my body is begging me to not love it.
42 isn't, my wife is often like, you're not going to become like a professional fighter.
You know that, right?
Like, you're a comedian.
But let me ask you something.
If we got into it, I would fuck you up.
问得太好了，因为爱好对我的生活和幸福也占据了极大的比重。所以，比如，我喜欢巴西柔术。我喜欢，尽管我的身体在求我别再爱它了。42岁可不……我妻子经常对我说：“你不会去当职业格斗手吧。你知道这不可能，对吧？你看，你是个喜剧演员。”不过我问你个问题。如果我们真打起来，我会把你打得屁滚尿流。
You'd fuck me up, right?
I would fuck all three of you us.
And that's the best part.
My favorite thing is people are like,
oh, Jonah Hill, fucking fat guy from Superbath, whatever.
And I'm like, I would fucking annihilate you, dude.
I'm not kidding, dude.
Because every fight ends up.
你会把我打得落花流水，对吧？我会把我们三个全都打得落花流水。这才是最棒的部分。我最喜欢的一点是，人们会说：“哦，乔纳·希尔，就是《太坏了》里那个该死的胖子，诸如此类。”而我会说：“我会把你彻底消灭的，老兄。”我不是在开玩笑，老兄。因为所有的打斗最终都会——
If you see me, try it, dude.
Every fight ends up on the ground.
Fucking bring it.
Who's got it?
I will, unless you are with.
bigger than me.
I have like a...
Fucking fuck around and find out.
如果你看到我，尽管来试试，老兄。所有的打斗最后都会倒在地上。尽管放马过来。谁行？我行的，除非你比我还……我有种……不作死就不会死。
And also, um, surfing.
Surfing.
But then your kids take all that, you know, it was all that stuff like, like pandemic,
no life, selfish, have no family, no wife.
But then, you know, kids, it's your life, dude.
You know, like it's, um, there is not a free moment.
Like I ask permission now to go do my hobbies.
You know?
还有，嗯，冲浪。冲浪。但后来孩子们占去了你所有的精力，你知道的，以前那种没生活、自私、没有家庭、没有妻子的日子……但后来呢，你知道的，有了孩子，这就是你的生活了，老兄。你知道的，比如，嗯，根本没有空闲时间。就像我现在做爱好都得先请示一样。你知道吗？
Because like if the kid needs, the kids need me.
Right.
You know, but then you've got to fill your own cup.
That's why I call guys with Jason, like Jason, to be like,
how do you balance this shit, you know?
I have a secret fantasy of wanting to get into a fight.
And, because I've never been into it.
It's not a fantasy.
因为如果孩子需要，孩子们需要我。对吧。你知道的，但接着你得照顾好自己的内心。这就是为什么我会给像杰森这样的人打电话，比如杰森，想问问：“你是怎么平衡这烂摊子的，你知道吗？”我有一个秘密幻想，就是想卷入一场打斗。而且，因为我从来没打过架。这可不是什么幻想。
I feel really bad for the other guy.
Sean just likes the ground and pound situation.
By the way, I'm being funny, by the way.
I would fuck you up, but I am being funny also.
You started, you like Jiu-Jitsu.
I'm going to start a new one called Ground and Pound.
Yeah, I'm going to teach it.
Groundupound.com is not what you think it is.
我真替另一个人感到难过。肖恩只是喜欢地面砸击的局面。顺便说一句，我在开玩笑。我会把你打趴下，但我也是在开玩笑。你先挑起的，你喜欢柔术。我要开创一个新的流派，叫“地面砸击”。对，我要去教这个。Groundupound.com可不是你想的那样。
Get it now.
Yeah, no, I've never been in a fight,
and I've always been like that.
It has to feel like...
But, dude, acting, and, like,
I hadn't acted in a long time,
and now I'm out there maybe going to take a role
and, like, start acting for other people.
现在就去注册吧。对，不，我从来没打过架，而且我一直都是这样。这必须感觉……但是，老兄，表演，而且，我已经很久没演戏了，现在我可能要接个角色，重新开始为别人演戏。
I'm so excited to act.
Like, almost like I'm excited about to serve for jujitsu.
Because you've been away for it a while,
or because of the directing,
and now you're going to bring that perspective to the acting?
Yeah, like I haven't done a movie where I acted for another director.
I did McKay's movie, Don't Look Up.
And then you people with Kenya, which was such a fun experience.
我对演戏感到太兴奋了。就像我对去冲浪或柔术一样兴奋。是因为你离开了一段时间，还是因为当导演的经历，现在你要把那种视角带回表演中？对，就像我好久没演过其他导演的电影了。我拍了麦凯的电影《不要抬头》。然后是和肯尼亚合作的那部，真是太有趣的经历了。
I saw Lauren London today.
Shout out Lauren London.
I fucking love you.
Shout out Kenya.
Shout out McKay.
Shout out all the homies.
And then what am I talking about?
And then so.
我今天见到劳伦·伦敦了。向劳伦·伦敦致敬。我他妈爱你。向肯尼亚致敬。向麦凯致敬。向所有的兄弟们致敬。然后我在说什么呢？然后呢。
Your hobbies.
Acting.
Yeah, like, I was like, I might take the job.
And I'm like, dude, I'm so excited to like just put on the t-shirt you tell me to put on and go be funny.
Like, I want to do, like, I'm so excited like I was when I was young.
And so that's a fun feeling, you know?
Yeah, I do know.
What about Daddy stuff?
你的爱好。表演。对，就像，我当时想，我可能会接下这份工作。然后我想，老兄，我太兴奋了，只想穿上你让我穿的那件T恤去搞笑。我想做，就像，我像年轻时一样兴奋。所以这是一种很有趣的感觉，你知道吗？是的，我懂。那关于当爸爸的事呢？
What's your favorite part about?
You were amazing, I called you, but you got to see, is this thing on?
Will was so incredible.
Brilliant.
Absolutely brilliant.
And Bradley's just an amazing thing, too.
So incredible.
Yeah.
你最喜欢的部分是什么？你太棒了，我给你打过电话，但你必须去看看，这个东西开着吗？威尔太不可思议了。绝了。绝对绝了。布莱德利也是个了不起的存在。太不可思议了。对。
Who don't you like?
I'm kidding.
I'm just kidding.
It's more like who doesn't like me, unfortunately.
What is your favorite part about Daddy stuff?
What have you found is your favorite thing to do with your?
kids that you didn't think, that you didn't know you were going to love.
I knew I was going to love it.
你不喜欢谁？我开玩笑的。我只是开玩笑。更确切地说是谁不喜欢我，不幸的是。你最喜欢当爸爸的哪个部分？你发现自己最喜欢和孩子们做什么事是以前没想到、也不知道自己会那么喜欢的？我早就知道我会喜欢。
I just prayed that I'd be able to do it in the right way.
You know, so I'm so proud of what I get to do.
Every second of it is so sick.
Because even when he's like three and crazy,
because one of the one of the one's a little baby,
you can only yell at him, scream yourself, horse at him so much.
But how's your swaddle game?
That was a joke.
我只是祈祷自己能够用正确的方式去做到这一点。你知道的，所以我为我所做的一切感到无比自豪。其中的每一秒都太棒了。因为即使当他三岁而且极其疯狂的时候——因为其中一个是小宝宝，你对他大喊大叫、吼到嗓子嘶哑也是有限度的——不过你的襁褓包裹技术怎么样？那是个玩笑。
How's your swaddle game?
Are you a good swaddler?
No, he's out of, yeah, no, I'm not a good swaddler.
I'm a good diaper change.
What's a good diaper change?
Nope, nope.
Yeah.
But there's a whole, swallower.
你的襁褓包裹技术怎么样？你是个裹襁褓的高手吗？不，他已经不用……对，不，我不是个裹襁褓的高手。我是换尿布的高手。换尿布算什么高手？不，不。对。但这里面有一整套，裹襁褓的人。
Swaddling is when you take and you wrap up.
Well, they're probably past, the young ones probably past the swaddling now.
Yeah.
I thought you said swallower.
No.
Swaddler.
That's on ground and pound.com.
It's, um.
裹襁褓就是你拿来然后把……好吧，他们可能已经过了，小家伙们现在可能已经不用裹襁褓了。对。我以为你说的是“吞咽者”（swallower）。不。裹襁褓者（swaddler）。那个在ground and pound.com上。它是，嗯。
Amanda, was Jason, did he get in the swaddle?
He did.
For real.
A great swaddler.
And a great diaper.
change your rougher.
Making your kid, like seeing your kid
come up with something that he thinks
阿曼达，杰森，他会裹襁褓吗？他会。真的。他是个裹襁褓高手。还是个换尿布高手。粗鲁点说。让你的孩子，就像看到你的孩子想出了某种他认为
is funny to make you laugh.
Like knowing that that's, like
he wants, he thinks of something
that is funny in his three-year-old mind
and then tries to be like
dada, and then says,
which is usually, oh, fuck or weiner,
because he's my son.
很好笑能逗你笑的点子。就像知道那是，比如他三岁的小脑袋里想出了一件好笑的事，然后试着喊“爸爸”，接着说出那个词——通常是“哦，操”或者“小鸡鸡”，因为他是我的儿子。
And he'll be like,
dad, da, oh, fuck.
And I'm like,
family business.
baby, get out there.
Are you enjoying, well, he's still a little bit to you, but like,
I'll bet you're going to enjoy starting to feather in, like,
your sense of humor to him, and, like, you know,
然后他会说：“爸爸，哒，哦，操。”而我会说：“家族企业，宝贝，去闯荡吧。”你是不是在享受——好吧，他对你来说还是有点小，不过——我敢打赌，你会很享受开始逐渐把你的幽默感融入到他身上，然后，你知道的，
he'll start to, like, pick up on that from you,
and it'll start to maybe become kind of his sense of humor, too.
Like, I remember, I think it was, I think it was Maple, was it you,
or was it Franny?
I remember, I'll never forget what time,
what of them said to be like, Daddy, how come you never smile after you say something funny?
And it was like, you know, just kind of like, well, because if you smile, then you know it's a joke.
But if you don't smile, then it's kind of dry and that's like sarcasm.
他会开始从你身上领会到这一点，这也许最终也会变成他的一种幽默感。就像，我记得，我想是，我想是梅普尔，是你吗，还是弗兰妮？我记得，我永远不会忘记其中一个对我说：“爸爸，为什么你讲完笑话从来不笑？”就好像，你知道的，那种感觉，就好像，“嗯，因为如果你笑了，那你就知道这是个玩笑。但如果你不笑，那听起来就有点干瘪，这就叫讽刺。”
Like, it was like so weird that I was trying to formulate what the answer would be to that.
But like you don't know what the answer is that.
It's just like...
Your kids have never seen you smile.
Think about that.
That's what it is.
Think about how fucking traumatized there.
Comedy is not supposed to be fun in our house.
就像，试图为那个问题寻找答案的过程是如此诡异。但你根本不知道答案是什么。这就好比……你的孩子们从来没见过你笑。想想看。事实就是这样。想想他们有多他妈受创伤吧。在我们家里，喜剧可不是用来开心的。
Stop laughing.
I mean, you don't have to teach them shit.
They just watch you.
Right, that's what I mean.
It's like, you start to just like, I don't know.
I just, I don't want to go tomorrow.
You're going to be brilliant.
别笑了。我的意思是，你根本不用教他们什么狗屁东西。他们只是看着你。他们只是看着你。对，这就是我的意思。这就像是，你开始只是像，我不知道。我只是，我明天不想去。你会表现得惊艳全场的。
I would be having a nervous breakdown if my kids were going to college.
Because I think about, I start crying sometimes.
I'm like a little baby myself because I'll look at them and be like,
if you're a teenager and don't want to hang out with me, I'll cry every night.
You know, like I can't imagine.
Imagine them out in the world and shit.
Somebody said to me that sort of like got me off the ledge,
when your kids go to college, you've got a long time to go.
如果我的孩子们要去上大学，我肯定会精神崩溃的。因为我想着想着，有时甚至会哭起来。我自己就像个小婴儿一样，因为我会看着他们然后想：“如果你成了青少年，再也不想跟我混在一起了，我每天晚上都会哭的。”你知道的，就像我无法想象。想象他们在广阔世界里闯荡什么的。有人对我说了一番话，把我从崩溃边缘拉了回来：当你的孩子们去上大学时，你还有很长的一段路要走呢。
They're not going to college, let's be honest.
Maple's got another four or five years,
so the tears are still pretty low.
But when Frannie, my eldest, left,
I was like, I'm not going to do well with this.
She goes to school in town, so I'm okay.
But somebody said to me a few years before she left,
she said, you're not losing your four-year-old.
他们才不会去上大学呢，说实话。梅普尔还有四五年呢，所以眼泪暂时还不会掉得太凶。但当弗兰妮，我的大女儿离开时，我想的是：“我可应付不来这事。”她在镇上上学，所以我还好。但在她离开前几年有人跟我说，她说：“你并不是在失去你四岁的孩子。”
like it's not your four-year-old is not leaving it's an 18-year-old that's probably been spending a lot of weekends out at friends house and stuff like so it gets feathered in and it's not like boom your your four-year-old your 10-year-old is like leaving the house it's it's you're actually excited for them to you know leave the nest start flapping the wings and it's it's and you've like knowing you relationship with your daughters you've seen them blossom into these incredible people so you're like go shred yeah yeah you're excited to watch them play the guitar you know
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Oh, you'll love it.
It's radical. It's all a blessing.
Yeah.
All right, we're about done here. These people, they probably want to pee or do something or get the hell out of here.
In closing, though.
We're done? Oh, my gosh.
We don't take a lot of time. I was so boring. What?
就像这并不是你四岁的孩子在离开，而是一个18岁的年轻人，她可能已经把很多周末都花在朋友家什么的了。所以这是一点点融入的，并不是说“轰”的一下，你四岁、十岁的孩子就要离开家了，其实你会为他们感到兴奋，你知道的，离开巢穴，开始拍打翅膀，而且，你了解你和女儿们的亲密关系，你看着她们绽放成这些了不起的人，所以你会想“去吧，尽情闯荡吧”。是的，是的，你很兴奋地看着她们弹吉他，你知道的。是的，是的，是的。哦，你会喜欢的。太酷了。这一切都是一种恩赐。是的。好了，我们这儿快结束了。这些人，他们大概想去嘘嘘或者干点别的，或者赶紧离开这儿。不过最后。我们结束了？哦天哪。我们没花多少时间。我太无聊了。什么？
Oh. Talk to us about the film that's out right now and the film that's coming out.
I saw that one too. That one's fucking great. You guys are going to have to wait a little bit longer on that.
You're still in post on that.
Jason also gives the best notes
because he's such a great director
and friends.
So, but tell us about...
It's here for Jason.
哦。跟我们聊聊现在正在上映的那部电影以及即将上映的那部电影吧。我也看过那部。那部他妈的太棒了。你们还得再等上一小会儿才能看到那部。那部还在后期制作中。杰森总是能给出最棒的意见，因为他既是个优秀的导演又是好朋友。所以，但跟我们讲讲……为杰森喝彩。
Incredible.
And Will and I are friends,
but it's like a newer friendship
and then Shannon and I are going to become friends.
That's right, right after this.
You're sleeping over tonight.
Yeah, we're going to watch Superbad tonight.
Yes, great.
太棒了。我和威尔是朋友，但这是种比较新的友谊，然后香农和我也要成为朋友了。没错，就是在这之后。你今晚要在我们这儿过夜。对，我们今晚要看《太坏了》。太棒了。
Beat him up.
Yeah.
If you'd like the shit beating out of you,
please let me know.
Sean's got a sing way.
Come on down to San Diego.
We'll treat you right.
You look in your rearview mirror.
把这家伙揍一顿。对。如果你想屁滚尿流的话，请告诉我。肖恩有他的一套方式。来圣迭戈吧。我们会好好招待你的。你看着后视镜。
I went to San Diego so Jonah could beat me up.
Traffic was a nightmare.
Scotty, let's go.
So tell us about these two films.
The new movie's called Outcome, and you can stream it on Apple.
It's Keanu Reeves and myself and Cameron Diaz
and the great Matt Bowmer, who's incredible.
And a bunch of amazing people, David Spade, Laverne Cox,
我去圣迭戈就是为了让乔纳揍我一顿。交通简直是场噩梦。斯科蒂，我们走吧。那么跟我们聊聊这两部电影吧。新电影叫《结局》，你可以在Apple上观看。主演有基努·里维斯、我自己、卡梅伦·迪亚兹，还有伟大的、不可思议的马特·波莫。还有一帮极其出色的人，大卫·斯佩德、拉弗恩·考克斯，
really amazing cast.
And it's a really funny movie.
And if you want to enjoy yourself at home
and then pause it and take a piss and get snacks and stuff,
you can totally go do that.
But it's also got filmmaker stuff in it.
Like you shot it beautifully and it's scored beautifully.
And it's like you're doing it.
阵容真的极其强大。而且这是一部非常搞笑的电影。如果你想在家自得其乐，然后暂停去上个厕所拿点零食什么的，完全可以去。但里面也有很有电影质感的东西。比如画面拍得很美，配乐也很棒。就像你在……
Thank you.
And then this next one...
This next one is just pure stupidity.
So it is just dumb.
Tell them what the concept is.
It's dumb.
I'm about to go on a run of just the dumbest shit
you've ever seen in your entire life.
谢谢。然后接下来这部……接下来这部纯粹就是脑残喜剧。所以它就是很蠢。告诉大家概念是什么。它很蠢。我接下来要拍一连串你这辈子见过最蠢的烂片了。
So I hope you left your brains at home.
So it's called Cutoff.
And Kristen Wigg and I play two dumbass,
rich kids in their mid-40s who get cut off by their rich parents,
played by Bet Midler and Nathan Lane.
Oh, that's great.
It is like stepbrothers, clueless trading places.
It's so great.
所以我希望你们把脑子都忘在家裡了。所以它叫《断绝经济来源》。克里斯汀·韦格和我饰演两个四五十岁的愚蠢富二代，被由贝特·米德勒和内森·朗饰演的富有父母断绝了经济来源。哦，那太棒了。这就像《非亲兄弟》、《独领风骚》、《交易所》。太棒了。
Classic comedy, and Kristen Wigg is the American treasure.
I've been so lucky.
My last two movies, Keanu Reeves and Cameron Diaz
and Kristen Wigg and Bett Midler and Nathan Lane.
I'm the luckiest guy, but it's going to be in theaters.
Shout out Mike and Pam and Jesse at Warner Brothers.
and we are trying to bring comedy movies back to the movie.
Yeah, man, it's about time.
经典喜剧，而克里斯汀·韦格是美国的宝藏。我太幸运了。我的最后两部电影，有基努·里维斯、卡梅伦·迪亚兹，还有克里斯汀·韦格、贝特·米德勒和内森·朗。我是最幸运的家伙，而且这部会在院线上映。向华纳兄弟的迈克、帕姆和杰西致敬。我们正努力把喜剧电影带回大银幕。是的，老兄，是时候了。
It's about time.
There haven't been enough comedy movies getting made,
and I think it's about time,
and I hope that you're, like, I'm glad you're leaving.
I'm glad you're leaving my talk.
To just making people laugh.
We want more of you, more often,
higher frequency, your brakes over,
是时候了。现在拍的喜剧电影太少了，我觉得是时候了，我希望你——就像，我很高兴你离开。我很高兴你离开我的访谈节目。去专心逗大家笑。我们需要你更多、更频繁地带来欢乐，你的假期结束了，
move back up from San Diego,
or at least get a little kid-a-terre.
I promise to try and make a movie every year
That's funny.
Please do.
Critics, do your best, you cock suckers.
And then I'm going to make people laugh, so fuck y'all.
That's great.
从圣迭戈搬回来，或者至少在那里买个小公寓。我保证每年都努力拍一部好笑的电影。求求你了。评论家们，尽情发挥你们的本事吧，这帮混蛋。然后我会把大家逗笑，所以去你的吧。太棒了。
I love that.
We love you, buddy.
We love you, John.
We love you.
Jonah Hill, God.
Jonah Hill.
Thank you.
I hope that's okay.
我太喜欢了。我们爱你，老兄。我们爱你，约翰。我们爱你。乔纳·希尔，天哪。乔纳·希尔。谢谢。希望这样可以。
I love you, dude.
I'm sorry I was like that.
No, that's okay.
We got to do the wrap-ups.
We got to do the wrap-up.
Sean, I find, is
the most genuine, warmest, sincere, attentive friend I could ever ask to have.
That's a true story.
我爱你，老兄。抱歉我刚才那样。不，没关系。我们得做总结了。我们得做个总结。我发现肖恩是我能要求拥有的最真诚、最温暖、最真挚、最体贴的朋友。这是个真实的故事。
That's very nice.
Will has all of that and just happens to make me laugh more than anybody I've ever met in my life.
Yes.
Oh, thank you.
You're pretty funny too.
Jason.
Take your time.
It's going to take a minute.
太好了。威尔具备这一切，而且刚好比我见过的任何人更能把我逗得哈哈大笑。是的。哦，谢谢你。你也挺搞笑的。杰森。慢慢来。这得花上一分钟。
To think of something?
you are, you're so Jason, you know?
Which is what we love about you.
You're just, you're the, no, Jason is such a sweet boy.
This is awkward.
No, it's true.
And he's, and he's, you've made such a great thing of yourself.
You've really turned around, I mean, you kind of grew up in the woods and you just, you got out and you're a beautiful person.
要想出点什么来？你就是，你太杰森了，你知道吗？这也是我们最喜欢你的地方。你就是，不，杰森是个多么甜美的小伙子。这气氛有点尴尬。不，这是真的。而且你，你把自己塑造得这么好。你真的咸鱼翻身了，我的意思是，你有点像是在树林里长大的，然后你走出来了，你是个美丽的人。
And he's, and I give him shit, we give him shit for being so, you know, grumpy and stuff.
But he's so squishy on the inside.
Yeah, yeah.
He is such a sweet.
Yes, I love you because you also are a genuinely kind person and you really think of other people.
And I, you are one of the, you're grabbing my ass right now.
Yeah.
And you're one of the smartest people I've ever known in my entire life.
而且他，我经常损他，我们都损他脾气怎么这么暴躁之类的。但他内心其实超级柔软。是的，是的。他是个如此甜心。是的，我爱你，因为你也是一个真正善良的人，你总是会为别人着想。而我，你现在正在抓我的屁股。是的。你是我这辈子认识的最聪明的人之一。
And, and yes, you're squishy inside.
This fella is also super squishy.
The funniest person on the face of the planet, both of them are.
and I love you guys both.
I love you too.
And I said, Sean and I were texting last night about something.
And I, you know, you have those moments.
One of the great things is about our friendship,
而且，是的，你内心很柔软。这家伙内心也超级柔软。地球上最搞笑的人，他们两个都是。我爱你们俩。我也爱你。我刚才说，肖恩和昨晚我们还在为某事发短信。而我，你知道的，你总会有那种时刻。我们友谊最美好的地方之一，
and I don't know why we're doing this,
but is we love each other.
And I think it's the age that we've gotten to
where we can tell each other that we love each other.
And it feels really great to be able to do that.
And I said, Sean sent me a text last,
we talked on the phone,
and then he sent me a really lovely text afterwards.
虽然我不知道我们为什么要这么做，那就是我们相爱。我觉得这也是因为我们到了这个年纪，可以互相倾诉我们爱彼此。能够做到这一点感觉真的很棒。我说，肖恩昨晚给我发了一条短信——我们通了电话，然后他随后给我发了一条非常温暖的短信。
And like Jason said, you cannot meet a person who is more consistently supportive and kind than Sean Hayes.
You can try.
No.
And constantly, he checks in on everybody he loves.
He's always so selfless and it's unbelievable.
And J.B.'s the same.
I feel very, very honored that we get to do that you guys listen to us.
Yeah.
就像杰森说的，你不可能遇到一个比肖恩·海耶斯更始终如一地支持你、关心你的人了。你可以去试试。不。而且他总是不断地向他爱的人表达关切。他总是那么无私，这简直难以置信。J.B.也是一样。我感到非常非常荣幸，能有机会让你们倾听我们。是的。
Fuck around.
I don't know if you guys get to work with your best friend.
They are truly my two best friends.
you guys let me work with them
and have the greatest time of my life
and talk to some of the most interesting people in the world
so we cannot thank you enough.
Yeah, we really, really appreciate it.
瞎胡闹。我不知道你们是否能和自己最好的朋友一起工作。他们真的是我最好的两个朋友。你们让我能和他们一起工作，度过我人生中最美好的时光，并与世界上一些最有趣的人交谈，所以我们对你们感激不尽。是的，我们真的非常非常感激。
Yeah, we do.
I also want to say sorry, thank you to Bennett
and to Rob and to Michael Granite.
There's Rob, Rob, Rob, put your hand up.
There's Bennett over there.
Yeah, John.
And where's Michael Terry?
Michael Terry somewhere.
是的，我们确实如此。我还想对贝内特、罗布和迈克尔·格兰特表达感谢。罗布，罗布，罗布，把手举起来。贝内特就在那边。是的，约翰。迈克尔·特里在哪里？迈克尔·特里在某个地方。
Michael Terry is somewhere.
It is six of us.
And our great partners is serious,
but it is the six of us that make this thing happen.
And so without them, we wouldn't have it.
And we didn't want to let another moment go.
Bye!
Bye, guys.
迈克尔·特里在某个地方。总共是我们六个人。我们伟大的合作伙伴是Sirius，但正是我们这六个人让这一切得以发生。所以没有他们，我们就不会拥有这一切。我们不想再错过任何一刻。拜拜！拜拜，伙计们。
Smartless is 100% organic
and artisanly handcrafted by Bennett Barbico,
Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Armjurf.
Smartless.
Smartless是一档100%有机、由贝内特·巴尔比科、迈克尔·格兰特·特里和罗布·阿尔姆朱夫手工打造的播客。Smartless。